[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour une nouvelle
édition à des matins du sénat les
missions qui vous fait vivre les travaux
de la haute assemblée je vous propose ce
matin de suivre une table ronde
organisée par le sénat sur les élus
locaux et les agences régionales de
santé pour faire le bilan de leur
coordination pendant la crise sanitaire
du corona virus pour rappel les agences
régionales de santé sont le relais de
l'état dans les territoires pour piloter
notamment le système hospitalier
je vous laisse écouter cette table ronde
d'années j'ai présidé le conseil
d'administration puis de surveillance
l'osce qui est un des plus grands
hôpitaux universitaires de france et
j'ai connu un peu cet été si
d'expérience
ces agences je le rappelle ce qui donc
vécu ses terres et aux anciennes en
place les anciennes agences régionales
de l'hospitalisation
créé en 1996 ainsi que du tout partie
des acteurs de la politique de santé
certains d'entre nous c'est mon cas ont
connu l'époque que les anciens services
déconcentrés du ministère de la santé et
les drass etc ou encore du côté de la
sécurité sociale les branches santé des
caisses régionales d'assurance maladie
alors peut-on dire sans aller trop loin
que globalement la loi hôpital patients
santé et territoires dite loi bachelot
et les ars sur les huld à l'époque
retirer au médecin d'un mot c'est le
service leur pouvoir sur les services de
soins trouver transféré au directeur de
l'hôpital en privilégiant et d'un poste
de gestionnaire
moi je ne dirais pas ça comme ça parce
que j'ai connu toutes les périodes de
crise elle d'abord elle système d'abord
il avait il faisait sens dans le monde
d'avant-hier mais il faut bien
reconnaître qu'il était aussi arrivé un
peu à la limite de l'exercice le des
vétérans un hôpital que j'ai bien connu
c'est vrai qu'il y avait des conneries
c'est vrai il y avait des moments
dirais-je des féodalités qui se
constitue et ça n'enlève rien à ce que
je dis évidemment la qualité des indes
et des soignants
à l'époque mais le le rôle d'un
directeur dont aujourd'hui complexe
il fait sans souci
et ce n'est pas forcément une signe
d'une démarche constamment conflictuelle
purement gestionnaire sans vision
beaucoup dépend aussi des personnalités
et capacités s'entendent des rôles du
rôle des présidences médecins les
commissions médicales d'établissement du
consensus qui se crée entre les
directions hôpital et les présidents ont
scellé surveillance et être souvent les
mères un qui joue aussi sans avoir à
pouvoir dans ce domaine un vrai rôle
tout n'a pas toujours été négatif mais
peu à peu on passait d'un système
perfectible dans un système à la
française dont on voit aujourd'hui les
limites
s'agissant du rapport au territoire
cette loi je prévois jeudi auprès de
cette instance de coordination notamment
avec les collectivités
un conseil de surveillance dans les
agences y aurait à dire sur sa
visibilité de son rôle une conférence
régionale de la santé d'autonomie je me
souviens que moi que je mets toujours
refusé d'y aller parce que j'avais le
sentiment que je n'ai pas le temps pour
ça également des commissions
coordination des politiques de certains
à faire des matches 1-1 qui ont
certainement fonctionner et si ou là
mais qui ont aussi marqué leurs limites
même si il avait une volonté de
transversalité avec la prévention la
sortie scolaire au travail la protection
maternelle et infantile et la prise en
charge d accompagnement médico sociaux
le système est donc arrivé à ses limites
certains se souviennent d'ailleurs que
lors de l'examen au parlement de cette
fois de 2009 agitée parlement à l'époque
j'étais au gouvernement mais je m'en
souviens aussi ça ne va pas passer
la certain nombre de propositions du
parlement notamment chénard n'ont pas
été prises en compte et qui aurait
peut-être pu permettre un meilleur
équilibre alors aujourd'hui et j'en
termine les ars les agences régionales
de la santé je vais trop distante des
territoires et d'autres institutions
associées les trop peu les acteurs
locaux
elle sauvait trop bureaucratique sur une
fragile face à des contextes de crise et
la coordination notamment en période de
crise grave
comme on l'a vécue par les greffés au
niveau des tas je parle du niveau et à
avec les ars d'un côté les rectorats de
l'autre comme il n'y avait pas
réellement d'autorité vous dire je
reconnus c'était de la recherche de
coordination permanente c'est parfois
compliqué sans parler de la relation
avec la victoire les régions les
départements tous à nos invités pour
témoigner nous à lattes et son jean
louis thiériot députés les républicains
de seine-et-marne président du conseil
départemental de seine-et-marne
je pense qu'il l'a été parce qu'il n'est
pas les deux en même temps avocat ou à
paris vous êtes également essayiste et
historien et biais le 9 avril dernier
dans le figaro une tribune très
intéressante que nous avons remarqué
intitulé l'efficacité de l'allemagne
contre le virus contredit l'argument du
manque de moyens de frédéric le bébé et
moi même sommes des frontaliers du prêt
à quelques kilomètres de l'allemagne est
montée d un système allemand c'est pas
nous qui allons contredire sur ce point
même si dans okapi tout n'est parfait
mais quand même il est parfois
intéressant de regarder ce qui marche à
côté
ensuite il ya dominique que du mot vous
êtes maire de verser sur star vice
président de l'association de la nrf le
soutien des maires de la sarthe
président des maires ruraux non vous
n'êtes pas que vous êtes président je
prie de m'excuser de l'association des
maires ruraux de france et président des
maires ruraux dassa vous êtes fait
connaître en prenant à l'arrêté
interdisant de tomber malade dans votre
commune c'est évidemment à un clin
d'oeil ironique et des provocateurs qui
avait pour but assumé de
protester contre le manque de médecins
dans des zones rurales en son temps vous
avez posé c'est le cas frédéric pierru
vous êtes maître de conférences en
sociologie chargé de recherche au cnrs à
l'université lille membres du collectif
direction d'un chaque santé de
sciences-po paris
vos travaux sont axés sur l'organisation
du système de santé français
en 2013 les abonnés du très critique sur
le bilan de la réforme des ae rays les
nombreux articles sur les hôpitaux
le dernier en date à paraître dans la
revue glénat s'intitule à la grèce
mission impossible
frédéric guéry vous êtes président les
républicains du conseil départemental
par depuis 2015 président de la
commission solidarité affaires sociales
de l'assemblée des départements de
france
vous avez été pendant vingt ans même
d'une la bourse entre de schirmeck dans
le nord de l'alsace est une sacoche subi
six mois j'étais maire de mulhouse
vous avez présenté en 2016 un rapport
sur l'avenir les politiques sociales
pour faire évoluer le modèle français
d'un mental de proximité ce qui enfin
nous sommes également très honoré de
vous avoir parmi nous genre de
kervasdoué vous avez été directeur
gérant les hôpitaux à une époque que que
j'ai déjà connu que mère et comme
président non de tout allait comme
parlementaire ou souviens très bien des
contacts que nous avions à l'époque d'un
routeur responsabilité aux attributions
correspondait à celle directeur de
l'hospitalisation et de l'organisation
des soins ministère de la santé
économique de la santé je peux dire qu'à
l'époque vous étiez un haut
fonctionnaire a inspecté sur le terrain
l'idée c'était pas de montrer du doigt
ce n'était pas dire non c'était
d'arriver à trouver de bons arguments
pour vous convaincre
lorsqu'on était forcée des territoires
est trouvé avec vous déterrez longtemps
car on savait que vous étiez ouvert à
l'argumentation la discussion est à la
recherche de terrains
donc que j'ai appris aux attributions
vous êtes l'économie de la santé
professeur émérite au conservatoire
national des arts et métiers aujourd'hui
vous êtes consultant spécialisé dans le
domaine de la santé et affaires venais
régulièrement dans les médias notamment
pour défendre une plus grande autonomie
des hospital vis-à-vis de l'état donc
nous disposons j'étais un tout petit peu
plus longue que d'habitude dans mon
introduction mais ces coûts talons
importante avec de nombreuses haltes et
nous avons normalement 1h30 environ
j'ai quelques demandes de parole et
transmis aux intervenantes à l'avancé
tout cas s'inscriront chemin faisant je
vais dès que j'aurai fini de parler se
prendraient les instructions vous pouvez
demander la parole chaque collègue il ya
la fonction converser si vous n'avez pas
déjà demandé par une crise précédemment
je salue donc les journalistes présents
et je reviendrai tout à l'heure sur des
mois quelques précisions à ce sujet dans
un deuxième temps je lui sur les pour
les collègues présents après l'audition
à nous aurons un petit coin je
présenterai sur les communes face à
l'inflation des prix de l'immobilier
mettez pas le monde comme nous avions
fait avant la crise à l'honneur et en
fait je propose que nous écoutions
d'abord et je le salue jean lui calé
jean louis thiériot monsieur le député
nous vous écoutons alors je propose que
nous avons un deux trois quatre cinq
intervenants vous auriez la parole
ensuite en réponse au sénateur si vous
pouviez de tenir et faire un peu mieux
que moi l'instant en 7 8 minutes
liminaire ce serait bien
je vous écoute je vous écris ton
monsieur gillioz merci monsieur le
président bonjour à tous je vais
m'efforcer de tenir dans ce créneau
alors d'abord ce que je veux préciser
c'est que les quelques propos que je
vais tenir sont ceux d'un observateur
d'un à titien
je ne suis pas spécialiste des questions
de santé
c'est à la fois comme ancien président
du département comme fait toujours
conseiller départemental ayant participé
à l'armement du centre opérationnel
départemental pendant la crise que je
vais te faire part de mon retour
d'espérer je propose de diviser même au
bout en deux phases d'abord l'expérience
de court terme que j'ai pu vivre et
après les quelques pistes d'amélioration
que je pourrai suggéré avant toute chose
je veux à nouveau rendre hommage aux
soignants comme nous le faisons tous les
éventuelles critiques que je poserai ne
sont éventrés évidemment pas à l'égard
du corps médical et du corps paramédical
qui a été exceptionnel qu'est ce que
j'ai constaté dans cette crise que
l'état sanitaire
c'est à dire les ars en l'occurrence
était peu adapté on va dire à la gestion
d'urgence
je prends trois exemples qui m'ont
absolument frappé c'est au moment de la
crise des masques
l'incapacité à gérer les flux
logistiques
nous avions une déléguée départementale
de la santé qu'ils étaient perdus qui a
été incapable de gérer de les livraisons
de gérer des stocks une logistique et
l'arrivée sur place et c'est nous qui
avons dû nous y substituer pour amener
les masques auprès des pharmaciens
c'est une difficulté à faire remonter
l'information
on a eu plusieurs cas d pad dans
lesquelles j'avais été informé par le
territoire qu' il y avait des drames qui
s'y déroulaient on nous disait les yeux
dans les yeux à moi même et au préfet ya
un mort mais ça n'est pas le code vide
et on découvrait dans le parisien la
semaine suivante qu'il y avait
17 morts et on est arrivé à un point tel
qu'il a fallu que ce soit le département
de seine-et-marne qu'ils fassent
remonter à l'état les informations que
nous avions de nos propres et pape
enfin un problème de juridisme permanent
et de parapluies autour du principe de
précaution poussé à l'extrême qui fait
que quand il fallait agir vite
on entendait le doux bruissement des
parapluies qui s'ouvre est pas
nécessairement de l'action donc je crois
une structure qui n'est pas organisé
pour gérer l'urgence
le problème au niveau départemental du
dualisme entre l'état représenté par le
préfet et l'autorité de santé et je
pense que dans une situation de crise
comme celle-là il est absolument
indispensable que la décision soit
centralisé au niveau de l'intérieur et
pour rebondir sur un des sujets que vous
avez évoqué le problème ne s'est pas
posée au niveau des directeurs
d'hôpitaux qui pour autant que je puisse
en juger ont été d'une grande efficacité
c'est vraiment au niveau de la rs
instance de coordination
après puisque je dois être bref et
partager une expérience générale le
sentiment que j'ai c'est que la
politique de santé sur un territoire et
notamment la carte hospitalière ne peut
pas être géré par une instance
administrative ou une agence une
organisation déconcentrés de l'état mais
doit être impérativement décentralisée
et ça a été une des analyses que j'avais
fait dans la tribune que vous avez eu la
gentillesse de cité sur l'allemagne le
ces éléments là sont du niveau de la
compétence des länder et je crois que
l'une de nos difficultés et qu'il n'y a
pas de responsabilité politique autour
de l'organisation de la carte spital
hier autour de l'organisation de la
santé sur un territoire et sans
responsabilité politique
on arrive à une vision très
technocratique des choses alors que les
seuls qui sont capables
je pense de comprendre vraiment le
besoin d'un territoire sont les
collectivités locales
alors je ne me prononcerai pas à ce
stade
ma religion n'est pas faite sur le
niveau décentralisation sous étape est
ce le niveau régional est ce le niveau
départemental je n'en sais rien mon
ancien casquette de président de conseil
départemental fait que jacqueline ray ou
plutôt pour le département je n'aurais
pas forcément 10 à 6 lorsque nous avions
encore 22 régions
mais quand vous voyez des régions xxl je
pense à la région grand est
chers collègues guéri ou 7 à strasbourg
que se décide le destin du département
de l'eau qui est frontalier de ma
circonscription faire de la dentelle
dans l'eau depuis strasbourg
je n'ai rien contre mais je pense que
c'est compliqué donc voilà en tout cas
cette décentralisation elle me semble
indispensable que ce soient des
responsables politiques qui décident de
cette carte spital hier de la
répartition sur le territoire
quitte à renier évidemment une
coordination au niveau national pour
qu'on n'ait pas des divergences trop
importantes
en sachant que je pense que dans ce cas
là on risquera plus tôt de faire plus
que pas assez parce qu'on sait à quel
point le sujet des déserts médicaux est
absolument prégnant dans nos territoires
l'autre point qui me semble important
dans ce dans cette nouvelle organisation
de la santé c'est la nécessité de
coopérer vraiment efficacement avec le
privé que ce soit la médecine de ville
la médecine libérale ou les cliniques
dans la crise du coc vide tout le monde
devaient ramer dans le même sens
tout le monde devait participer à la
mise en place de la stratégie au niveau
local j'ai assisté à l'absence totale de
coordination avec les médecins libéraux
avec les infirmiers libéraux ou avec les
cliniques ou pas trop chez moi ça s'est
réglé au bout d'une dizaine de jours
on avait des cliniques mobilisés et on
ne leur en voyait aucun patient alors
que les hôpitaux étaient sous tension
voilà vous m'avez demandé d'être bref
monsieur le président je me suis efforcé
de l'être et je me fais un plaisir de
répondre à toutes les questions précises
mes propos ne secoue une charge contre
personne mais simplement l'objectif
d'être le plus efficace et en clair ça
veut dire proximité responsabilité
politique et l'union de tous les acteurs
et attend de l'efficacité allemand merci
j'ai rejoint lui thieriot vous avez
donné d'emblée en effet le bon exemple
de la concision avec un os néanmoins
très fort et intéressant est ce que jean
de kervasdoué qui a manifesté le souhait
de combat parole souhaite parler à la
fin des intervenants comme je l'avais
l'histoire tout de suite
jean je préfère moi je préférais que
vous parlez à la fin si ça ne vous
dérange pas vous aurez que vous êtes
tous les deux les bulls à dieu ça je ne
sais pas vous vous un peu plus que moi
sage évidemment alors merci aux gens
c'est parce doute la parole à dominique
dhumeaux à présent maire de percé succès
et président des maires ruraux de france
face aux vice présidents pardon bien sûr
vous avez la parole merga fier oui oui
bien sûr les vice-présidents et je suis
un peu en charge sur le des sujets de
santé au sein de l'association même si
ça n'a rien à voir avec avec ma
spécialité c'est simplement parce que
c'est un sujet qui m'intéresse et je
suis surtout dans un département qui est
en souffrance pour l'accès aux soins
je partage totalement les propos de et
merci monsieur présent de donner la
parole
je partage tout à fait les propos qui
ont été exprimées jeudi par le par
moscou 0 et loriot sur sur la situation
et sur le vécu nous avons sur le
territoire en ait des liens avec la
herray ch
dans le cadre d'ailleurs de l'agenda
rural michaud à laquelle j'ai participé
avec quatre autres collègues
nous avions déjà sur ce sujet-là alerté
le gouvernement sur la difficulté nous
avions nous élus de comprendre un peu le
rôle des ars et et surtout des liens
inexistant entre entre les élus que le
som et et cette institution qui est loin
de tout et souvent inaccessibles pour le
dialogue
je suis moi c'est encore pompier de
profession et au début de la crise j'ai
été assez surprise de voir que que le
gouvernement avait fait le choix de
s'appuyer sur les agences régionales de
santé pour cette crise alors que depuis
2008 il est à finances des zones de
défense et de sécurité qui sont souvent
qu'il était mise en place justement pour
gérer ce type de crise et qui n'ont pas
du tout et d alerter qui n'ont pas être
du tout était utilisé en inde et au
départ de la crise comme un outil pour
gérer cette crise ce qui est
certainement une des causes essentielles
des difficultés qu'on lui lé préfet a
travaillé derrière avec les airs est
soudan durant la crise
parce que parce que évidemment les
préfets n'avaient pas forcément
l'habitude de travailler krs d'ailleurs
comme que de difficultés beaucoup de
difficultés pour travailler avec la
direction académique 1 dans les
départements parce que si souvent des
ministères j'en ai aidé des services de
l'état qui fonctionne en silo et qui ont
beaucoup de difficultés à se remettre
autour de la table et et à partager
leurs expériences sur leurs
problématiques et quand on discute avec
les traités dans de nombreux
départements se rend compte que c'est
une des vraies difficultés de travailler
en commun avec les rs mais aussi avec
les directions académique grand laxisme
et et drôle a pris soin ou depuis depuis
deux jours et sachant comme sont bien
disponibles aujourd'hui de se rapprocher
de nos collègues maires ruraux pour
avoir un peu lors le rapt leur vision du
rôle des ars durant la crise mais aussi
avant cette crise et force est de
constater qu'en fait on voit bien que
personne n'a de contacts avec eux avec
des aéré ch
à partir du moment où on n'est pas un
élu d'un d'une fille d ayant un centre
hospitalier
sur son périmètre un les lignes que
c'est très très peu de contacts avec ces
agences et que et c'est une vraie
difficulté parce que bien évidemment ça
contribue à rendre des décisions de ces
agences difficilement applicable souvent
son excision qui font plutôt des dégâts
dans le territoire
si on devait en retenir qu'une chose ce
serait l'obligation de t'avoir deux
médecins lorsqu'on veut faire une maison
de santé pluridisciplinaire sur son
territoire alors que nous avions besoin
d'un seul médecin auparavant qui avait
freiné quasiment en quelques en quelques
jours toutes les initiatives que nous
pouvions avoir passé évidemment donnera
territoire en inde et en situation de
demande aux médecins et d'imposer de
médecins généralistes e prix maison de
chanter évidemment la meilleure des
solutions pour que aucune maison de
santé puissent se mettre en place sur
les territoires les plus les plus en
difficulté quand on échange ensuite avec
nos collègues ont là une certaine à 100
un sentiment d'opacité dans les dents
les aussi d'aller dans les décisions ou
dans les rues dans les décisions des
agences régionales qui ce qui rendait
encore plus difficile le rôle des maires
surtout dans les zones les plus touchées
du grand est où les élus souvent avait
un besoin d'avoir le tas d'appréhender
la situation au sein de leur commune
pour voir si la population était et est
touché et nécessité de la part de
l'équipe municipale une réactivité
différentes et il n'y avait aucune
possibilité d'avoir au moins en terme de
chiffres un pourcentage de personnes
susceptibles d'être d'être contaminés ce
qui rendait forcément surtout début de
la crise le rôle des élus compliqué et
alors que la grèce aurait eu un rôle
important à jouer sur ce sujet là tout
en restant très très neutre et tout en
confirmant évidemment toutes les données
qui méritent de l'être
mais on a vraiment au moins les
collègues maires sur le pourcentage
grosso modo des personnes touchées sur
un périmètre donné aurait certainement
accompli et était un immense une très
bonne information pour leur permettre
d'être un encore un peu plus réactif
autrement on a évidemment les mêmes on a
beaucoup de traits fait un kiki qui se
sont plaints auprès de collègues maires
dans différents départements des
difficultés avec les restes et il faudra
à tout prix s'en souvenir mais si on
devait retenir une leçon essentielle
c'est que la grèce n'était pas fait pour
une crise que c'est ministère de la
santé qui s'est emparée du sujet
immédiatement et qui a été taclé sur les
rs parce qu'il me connaissait que ça a
saigné autre regard à nous qu'on a sur
nous sur ces crises et que évidemment ça
rendait des choses difficiles si demain
on devait réfléchir au drs et si on
devait corriger les choses se seraient
ce serait d'intégrer les élus bien
évidemment danser dans son mode de
fonctionnement
aujourd'hui les seules élections
présence des élus des communes ou des
centres hospitaliers sont en place assez
le regarde qu'on en a nous en tout cas
et évidemment le souhaiterions nous être
intégrés dans les dents les cp tech dans
dans les différentes réunions drs au
niveau départemental pour apporter notre
regard peut-être aussi précisé des
difficultés que nous avons pour l'accès
aux soins
je suis moi dans un département en
grande difficulté sur l'accès aux soins
avec un nombre de médecins généralistes
bien inférieur à la moyenne nationale
avec une moyenne d'âge avec plus de la
moitié des médecins généralistes y ont
plus de 60 ans ou l'un a même une
vingtaine qui ont plus de 70 ans qui
cherche toujours
on sait qu'aujourd'hui yeux contre 4,204
médecins partent à la fête
seulement 2 arrive donc on sait bien
évidemment que ce ne sera pas la
solution des mac il va falloir trouver
d'autres solutions que la
téléconsultation est une des pistes et
que la rs avait bloqué ce système qui
s'est déverrouillé pendant la crise mais
qui risque de nouveau d'être bloquée à
la suite de cette crise alors c'est
quand même un outil assez intéressant au
moins pour les renouvellement des
ordonnances ya des consultations magique
pour désengorger les salles d'attentes
qui vont se remplir très rapidement
la crise et c'est à travers notre
présence dans ce type d'instance que
nous pourrons faire valoir nos les
besoins de nos administrés et faire en
sorte que les restes deviennent des
rêves deviennent enfin un vrai outil de
santé publique et qui qui permettent à
des départements comme les autres de ne
pas rester en ce sens le plus longtemps
voilà ce que nous avons au début de cet
échange
merci beaucoup et demi que du beau
monsieur le maire pour ce propos à la
fois concret l'un d'eux de bon sens
comme d'ailleurs avant vous jean louis
triaud et avant de passer la parole à
frédéric pied lui je voudrais vous
confirmez je n'ai pas été suffisamment
clair
en introduction de notre vos dition que
nous sommes également en direct sur
public sénat voilà cette précision étant
apportés je passe la parole et donc à
frédéric pierru que j'ai présentée tout
à leur maître de conférences en
sociologie chargé de recettes de
recherche au cnrs et à l'université de
lille et qui a donc une réflexion
intéressante et pointue sur la réforme
le bilan de la réforme des adresses
génériques pierru vous êtes la micro le
micro est branché pensez-vous du micro
s'il vous plaît et vos caméras
la caméra sinon je pense à vous voilà
que vous voyons nous vous écoutons bien
merci monsieur le président donc et
bonjour à toutes et tous vous avez dit
tout à l'heure en présentant que j'avais
fait un article ou d'un et des articles
extrêmement critique sur les ars en fait
c'est pas des articles critiques sur les
agences régionales de santé dont je vois
qu'elles peuvent être constitués en
boucs émissaires à l'occasion de cette
crise du de la copie de 19 mais plutôt
du de la mauvaise naissance des agences
régionales de santé
il m'explique sous les cordes la loi
hôpital patients santé territoires au
moment de son élaboration il ya eu deux
conflits moi j'ai suivi ça j'ai fait une
enquête de longue haleine sur 7 sur
cette période
il ya eu deux conflits il ya eu un
conflit avec la caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie qui voulait garder
la main sur la médecine libérale et puis
un conflit avec les préfet qu'on voit
resurgir aujourd'hui à l'occasion de
cette crise autour
alors je vais venir sur les prêts faits
mais quand même il a été dit tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait une mauvaise
coordination des ars sur avec les
médecins libéraux qui ont été un peu
mise à l'écart a et c
mais j'ai envie de dire les agences
régionales de santé n'ont jamais eu la
main sur la médecine libérale un donc
même s'il y a une compétence partagée en
matière de gestion du risque
en fait la cnam à préserver son pré
carré
à l'occasion de la loi hôpital patients
santé territoires donc je dirais que là
déjà il ya une malfaçon ou une mauvaise
constitution de naissance des agences
régionales de santé elles sont censées
avoir la main sur l'ensemble de l'offre
de soins est en réalité elles n'ont la
main que sur le seul hôpital
et encore cette main sur l'hôpital était
étroitement bordé par le niveau national
par exemple la dg os suis les centres
hospitaliers et puis le cabinet du
ministre les laisser à chute donc
donc je dirais que les ars ce sont des
colosses entraver un et dans le médico
social
les ars partagent leurs compétences avec
les collectivités territoriales
il revient maintenant au deuxième
conflit et c'est là où j'ai été assez
surpris le avec les préfet parce que les
préfets effectivement mal vécu
l'installation d' agences régionales de
santé qui leur échappe et c'est à dire
qu'avant il avait effectivement
l'autorité hiérarchique sur les das et
les drass et de fait ils ont perdu la
main sur les compétences se sent paix et
il ya eu un conflit là ça va peut-être
vous intéressé il ya eu un conflit au
moment de l'élaboration de la loi hpst
autour de la veille et de la sécurité
sanitaire et notamment de la question de
la surveillance épidémiologique avec et
cellule interrégionale d'épidémiologie
et les préfets voulait garder la main
sur je dirai tout l'aspect sécurité
sanitaire des agences régionales de
santé
et finalement on a trouvé là encore une
espèce d'armes
bancal où généralement normalement tous
les moyens dédiés à la sécurité
sanitaire dans les agences régionales de
santé moyens humains des expertises
devait passer sous l'autorité du préfet
avec une unité de commandement ce qui
est bien compréhensible
or donc il ya eu il ya eu un armistice
un compromis qui a été élaboré et dont
on voit qu'il était aussi complètement
bancal à l'occasion de cette crise
puisque et comme il a été très bien
rappelé les préfets ont des relations
assez mauvaise en général avec les
agences régionales de santé donc j'ai
envie de dire que cette crise ducobu de
19 à révéler les malfaçons originel de
2d des agences régionales de santé c'est
la raison pour laquelle je pense qu' il
serait fort dommage d'en faire des boucs
émissaires données entre responsables de
deux choses pour lesquelles elles n'ont
pas été faites
bon ensuite sur la question des élus
locaux alors là aussi c'est c'est là
encore on révèle la place des élus
locaux dans la gouvernance du système de
santé mais j'ai envie de dire là encore
on s'est laissé abuser par la notion de
territoire voyez la territorialisation
qui est devenu le leitmotiv faut des
politiques publiques de santé depuis
depuis 10 ans 15 ans 1 - ch à des fins
de fait un décompte pédant hpst le mot
territoire est employé 71 fois en 87
pages dans la loi de touraine de 2016 le
mot territoire est utilisé sans six fois
en 111 pages et dans la dernière loin le
26 mars du mak 26 mars 2019 qu'iter fait
référence 110 x 194 pages
donc on a une véritable inflation ou de
l'utilisation de la notion de territoire
et alors c'est c'est d'autant plus
surprenant c'est très surprenant cette
inflation dans l' usage du mot
territoires et des élus et de la
proximité de la territorialisation des
politiques de santé que en fait la
réalité de de l'évolution de la
gouvernance du système de santé
notamment du point de vue du régulateur
sont les agences régionales de santé
c'est la centralisation croissante
c'est à dire qu il est clair que la loi
hpst a été fait pour contourner les élus
locaux notamment parce que ces derniers
étaient vus comme des freins aux
restructurations hospitalières donc
là encore la difficulté des élus locaux
et notamment des élus ruraux à avoir des
contacts et des relations avec les
agences régionales de santé n'est pas
une anomalie puisque c'était finalement
je dirais le le coeur du projet hôpital
patients santé et territoire
c'est-à-dire éloigner le régulateur
régional de la pression des élus locaux
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs on a dépossédé les préfets 1
et leur relation de proximité avec les
élus locaux pour les confier à des
directeurs généraux des ars tôt que j'ai
envie de dire là encore une fois on sait
qu'il ne faut pas se laisser abuser par
l'aspect territorialisation qui est
devenue une incantation mais qui en fait
ne correspond pas à la logique qui a
présidé à aux transformations de la
gouvernance du système de santé depuis
depuis maintenant 11 ans là encore je
tiens à rappeler que c'est la même chose
du point de vue de la médecine libérale
et de la médecine de proximité puisque
finalement on a assisté en parallèle à
la centralisation de la décision aussi
du point de vue du financeur qui a eu
aussi le régulateur de la médecine
libérale c'est à dire la caisse
nationale nationale d'assurance maladie
autrement dit en l'exemple des
délégations départementales
quand je veux dire les délégations
départementales elles ont été vidés de
leur contenu
elles ont été vidés et ça a été voulu
comme tel c'était moi je me souviens
d'avoir interviewé madame emmanuelle
wargon quand elle était secrétaire
général des ministères sociaux
l'objectif c'était justement de ne pas
reproduire le modèle préfectoral ddas et
de en quelque sorte recentraliser au
siège tout ce qui pouvait l'être
donc en quelque sorte il me semble que
ce qu'on vit avec l'avion de cette crise
et l'évanescence de l'état sanitaire au
plan infrarégionales est évidemment qui
a été encore renforcée avec les grandes
régions enfin peut-être alors deux
pistes d'évolution parce que je ne veux
pas parler trop longtemps deux pistes
d'évolution alors réformer les agences
régionales de santé mais est ce que
c'est les agences régionales de santé
seul qu'il faut réformer certainement un
c'est à dire c'est l'ensemble du cadre
de la loi hpst qu'il faut réformer donc
soin en quelque sorte on leur donne un
vrai pouvoir décisionnel ce qui
renverrait nécessiterait par exemple une
montée en charge du fonds d'intervention
régionale 1 qui a complètement
stagner c'est à dire donner la main aux
directeurs régionaux aux directeurs
généraux des ars vraiment des vrais
moyens pour impulser financièrement des
politiques territoriales de santé et
surtout en asie deuxième volet si on
voulait réformer les ars redonner à
l'état sanitaire le plus local
c'est-à-dire les délégations
départementales des frais moyens humains
d'expertisé décisionnelle pour pouvoir
en quelque sorte conduire une vraie
territorialisation des politiques de
santé
un modèle plus révolutionnaire une
option plus révolutionnaire ça serait
d'aller vers les primary care trusts al
anglaise
c'est à dire que en fait on donne la
main à une structure qui gère l'ensemble
d'offre de soins dans un resort
d'environ 60 mille habitants d'accord
c'est à dire la main c'est à dire
vraiment a au contraire des ars d'avoir
la main sur la médecine libérale
l'hôpital le médico social et la
prévention donc des compétences pleine
et entière dans un ressort relativement
restreint puisque les grandes régions
c'est clair elles sont trop grandes
et puis en assurant la représentation
des élus locaux au board de c2c
scriptures qui serait en charge de la
pilote du pilotage des politiques de
santé dans un cadre évidemment
nationalement fixée au au plan le plus
local
voilà merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
fédérer que j'ai vu de ce coco bien
senti nous allons à présent écouter un
homme de terrain
un président de conseil départemental
qui eux essaient également de réfléchir
sur le sens de son de son action et
notamment sur ces sujets frédéric que
kiabi donc que président du conseil
départemental du parrain je vous ai
présenté tout à l'heure mais là je donne
d'emblée la parole chiffre élevé frais
levés vous étiez là tout à l'heure à
hier alors cherche un mari merci merci
bonjour à toutes et à tous chers amis et
élus sénateurs et sénatrices j'ai vu
dupilet en écoutant les trois premiers
intervenants et je me retrouve beaucoup
dans leurs propos mais je vais peut-être
ajouter quelques éléments
complémentaires
bien évidemment aujourd'hui on évoque la
crise du coc vide mais ça nous aura pas
échappé que le premier ministre a
annoncé le plan haute administration
ségur santé et puis on a en perspective
la loi autonomie qui vont bientôt venir
c'est autant de deux points importants
qui justifie de remettre à plat
l'organisation du service public de
santé à la fois de proximité d'offre de
soins aux personnes fragiles et d'offres
spital hier je crois qu'il est
nécessaire aujourd'hui de clarifier les
rôles entre l'état et les acteurs locaux
la crise finalement la clé du co lead
elle a mis en relief ce que nous
ressentions nous au quotidien de
l'action sanitaire mais on l'a ressenti
encore de plus de manière encore plus
criante
c'est l'inadaptation de la rs aux
besoins de santé et médico-sociaux des
territoires alors bien évidemment je ne
mets pas en cause les les personnes
je les ai vus dans cette crise
tous les salariés de l'aef qui font un
travail remarquable qui s'investissent à
fond dans cette crise et qu'ils donnent
le meilleur d'eux mêmes mais offre il
déplore eux-mêmes l'organisation du
service de la chasse
alors pourquoi ça ne fonctionne pas
plusieurs points d'abord effet été dit
par les précédents intervenants le
périmètre
aujourd'hui des grandes régions est
inadaptée moi je le vois aujourd'hui
dans la région grand test avec 10
départements c'est trop grand c'est trop
éloigné pour être agile jeu pour
l'anecdote je disais récemment j'ai eu
de raison d'y en abuser je ne voyais
plus souvent la ministre la santé que
mon directeur d'aï rs et mes collègues
présidents de départements me disais
qu'au bout d'un an certains d'entre eux
n'avaient pas encore vu le directeur de
l'ars est quand on sait aujourd'hui le
rôle médico social sanitaire important
que jouent les départements en lien et
qui devient nécessaire avec les ars
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui ce périmètre
est du coup inadapté ce périmètre
c'est aussi qu'ils aient des
méconnaissances derrière les
territoriales moi je me souviens quand
la grèce était encore à l'échelle 1 les
as j'avais un contact régulière je
n'étais pas président de département à
l'époque qu'on simplement conseiller
départemental est maire mais je voyais
régulièrement le directeur d'aï rs et on
avait un travail au quotidien sur le
terrain notamment sur les sujets de
d'offres hospitalière plus grave encore
en organisant des périmètre élargi
on a créé des concurrences entre le chu
moi je vois aujourd'hui ce qui peut se
passer entre le chu de nancy le chu de
strasbourg
on déplace des services sans tenir
compte des densité urbaine
finalement on a créé des tensions là où
il en existait pas donc ce périmètre
première marque inadapté deuxième
remarque incapacité à franchir le
dernier kilomètre du service on l'a
particulièrement vu là dans le
dans la situation du coc vide où on a
été amené
heureusement agir avec les avec la
société civile avec les acteurs locaux
pour suppléer aux carences notamment
pour les masquer
c'était dramatique collègues thieriot le
disais tout à l'heure si nous n'avions
pas été là on aurait à déplorer des
décès en plus et d'ailleurs des
professionnels sont extraits mis en
retrait parce qu'ils n'étaient pas
couverts en masque en tenue et ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas seulement les ehpad que
nous avons livré mais aussi les hôpitaux
au moi j'ai amené à l'hôpital
universitaire de strasbourg à la fois
des sur blouses des masques et état il
ya eu des vrais besoins qui n'étaient
pas couverts
donc la logistique l'agilité elle était
territoriale et du coup porté par les
élus locaux
je parle bien sûr du département mais
aussi les maires les communes où tout le
monde a été très a été très engagée dans
les liens aussi du quotidien avec les
ehpad
moi je vois j'ai très très tôt quand la
crise a été annoncée puisque nous étions
organisés déjà territorialement j'ai pu
faire un lien quotidien avec les ehpad
qui me permettait de connaître tous les
jours l'état sanitaire de chaque ehpad
les personnels touchés les les
pensionnaires touchées par la maladie de
nombre de décès et on a bien vu au cours
de cette crise que parfois la grèce ne
savait pas réellement la situation des
décès on donne souvent les décès
hôpitaux me donne pas les décès goût de
de la maladie est tout simplement parce
que il n'ya pas ce lien direct qui se
fait entre les établissements et les les
structures donc du coup de la rs donc là
vraiment incapacité à franchir derniers
kilomètres ça s'est vu mais monsieur le
maire tout à l'heure monsieur du mot
évoqué l'absence de lien entre les
maires et la rse au quotidien troisième
motif de satisfaction menée là sur un
système administratif qui est à la fois
coûteux
et construit essentiellement sur du
contrôle administratif directeur du chu
me disait qu'il avait pratiquement 2 à 3
personnes qui payent qui consacraient
leur temps au quotidien à répondre à des
questionnaires administratif de la rs on
est sur des démarches très cloisonné on
n'a pas d' approche globale
aujourd'hui des enjeux sanitaires et des
dépenses sanitaires
un exemple que j'ai connu en tant que
maire un hôpital de proximité a mis en
place un service de chimiothérapie ont
ce système avait un certain coût pour ça
et de cette clinique
la rs a vu de loin ce coût
supplémentaire pour cette clinique sans
tenir compte des économies faites en
termes de déplacements joie cette
clinique est basée à 50 kilomètres de
strasbourg laisser des gens pour les
soigner sont obligés de faire 100 km du
coup par jour c'est le coût des
déplacements n'avaient pas été intégrés
dans le coût global du service santé si
on tient compte du coup le bal c'est
moins cher d'avoir un service de
chimiothérapie décentralisée dans cette
clinique que de faire déplacer les gens
mais sauf n'y a pas cette vision là
global qui fait que du coup on voulait
supprimer ce service de chimiothérapie
scène c'est un exemple mais des exemples
ainsi y en a énormément la double
habilitation ehpad
aujourd'hui on a une administration une
une habilitation dépendance une
habilitation soins 1 du département
l'autre
la santé ça fait double travail
administratif
alors qu'aujourd'hui on aurait besoin de
personnel humain en accompagnement des
personnes âgées donc on voit bien
système et satif coûteux beaucoup de
contrôles administratifs ont pour effet
beaucoup de schémas beaucoup de machin
je suis là a permis d'en parler de
machin on est on est dans cette logique
autres éléments d'insatisfaction les
besoins sanitaires du médico social ne
sont pas prises en considération
ac aujourd'hui nous département dans
cette responsabilité protection de
l'enfance
le pmi handicapés personnes âgées en
particulier
on voit bien aujourd'hui par exemple sur
le on a des troubles du comportement
psychique de des enfants placés et on
n'a aucune réponse sanitaire sur ces
questions là on est en souffrent de
l'absence d'action pédopsychiatrique
absolument nécessaire en fait mais on
est en jeu voulait mettre en avant ses
c'est cette inadaptation de la rs aux
besoins du quotidien du sanitaire anses
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut attendre de
l'état
c'est bien sûr de fixer les objectifs de
santé à partir des réalités sanitaires
de notre pays c'est bien sûr de
valoriser financièrement et
statutairement les métiers du soin à la
personne ça c'est je crois que c'est
vraiment à l'échelle nationale que ce
cas est maître doit être travaillée mais
pour relever les enjeux du service
public de santé
c'est la sphère publique territoriale
seul qui est en capacité de le faire à
mes yeux
alors pour moi c'est qui la sphère
publique territoriale c'est bien sûr le
département en regard de ses compétences
qui existe déjà sur le champ sanitaire
médico social et social et je pense
qu'il faut décloisonner c'était les
noirs c'est ensuite le bloc local
communes intercommunalité
je crois que les maires dans dans les
villes avec le lien partie privilégiés
qu'ils peuvent avoir avec l'offre
hospitalière doivent avoir un pouvoir
aussi d'actions retrouver parce qu'il a
été malheureusement réduit à sa portion
la plus congrue
et puis dans la sphère publique
territoriale on a besoin aussi des
services déconcentrés de l'état je vais
y revenir
alors pourquoi je pense que les élus
plutôt qu'un service d'amener
administratifs de l'état sont plus à
même de jay est d'abord parce que les
agents les agents de l'état leurs yeux
ils sont responsables devant leur
hiérarchie nous on est responsable et
lui devant nos concitoyens et notre
inefficacité nous et nous on ne le
rappelle très rapidement si nous ne
sommes pas en réactivité et en agilité
face
au problème je vais vous donner un
exemple pour illustrer mon propos
quand un agent de la rs va visiter un
ehpad il va aller voir le directeur
il va vérifier que le bâtiment est aux
normes que tout le fonctionnement
administratif
étonnant un élu il va faire ça bien sûr
mais il ira ensuite voir les personnels
il verra les pensionnaires les familles
des pensionnaires parce qu'il les
connaît parce qu'il est sur le terrain
et que du coup il va voir si ce qui
dysfonctionne aussi dans l'organisation
vous donner un exemple pour les épaves
je vous avais peut-être due par entendu
parler des espaces nous hélène alors les
espaces nous n dans un espace un espace
où on doit être dans la détente pour
ceux qui vivent des problèmes de santé
s'était ans doit et on est sur des et
des coussins on est sur des lits yahoo
etc
c'est un lieu extraordinaire normalement
pour pour améliorer son quotidien
alors quand on regarde ces les espaces
aussi c'est fabuleux de la chance les
pensionnaires des départs puis tout à
l'heure ensuite vous allez discuter avec
les familles des pensionnaires et le
personnel demandé est ce que votre père
c'est ce que est ce que vous êtes allé à
l'espace nous élèvent pour constate que
l'espace noûn des rennais depuis un an
mais que les personnes n'ont pas le
temps d'y aller nous jamais la
possibilité d'aller parce que les
personnels n'ont pas le temps d'emmener
ce que les pensionnaires à ces espaces
là et ça vous ne le le le plus personnel
administratif des restes en aura pas
conscience c'est l'élu de terrain parce
qu'il a un échange il va avoir un
échange direct avec les pensionnaires
qui pourra le mettre en avant donc l'élu
il vérifiera bien sûr la qualité du
service mais aussi l'humanité du service
et je pense que c'est aussi une attente
très forte de nos concitoyens rare pour
conclure j'étais un peu long mais
quelles sont les propositions qui
peuvent être faites
donc moi je pense qu'il faut organiser
la gestion de la santé à partir des
territoires donner un rôle de chef de
file à au département pour mieux
coordonner le sanitaire et le médico
social ça se fasse tout cela en lien
avec le bloc local avec les services
déconcentrés de l'état et d'autres l'ont
dit avant moi je crois que le préfet
doit reprendre la main sur
la rs il doit les doigts par mon avis
avoir une dépendance hiérarchique
vis-à-vis du préfet on l'a vu
particulièrement dans cette crise je
pense que c'est important que l'ensemble
des services de l'état avec une vision
globale de l'offre de la santé avec cet
enjeu aussi de prévention de la santé
c'est un fait important et il faut qu'on
construise on l'a déjà fait dans
certains endroits et ça donnait sa
pertinence confins des contrôles aux
deux des contrats locaux de santé
médico-sociaux et sociaux condé posen
ces trois thématiques la sénégas à
partir de cette réalité locale en lien
avec les les professionnels de santé
aussi du privé qu'on pourra avoir
connaissance à la fois de la réalité
sanitaire des besoins sanitaires et des
réponses à apporter
il faut ensuite réduire les périmètres
des ars pour garantir une connaissance
territoriale et ça a été dit aussi tout
à l'heure par monsieur pierru
aujourd'hui les délégués départementaux
n'ont aucun pouvoir décisionnel ce n'est
pas possible
aujourd'hui il faut que sur le terrain
on puisse est en réactivité et en
injecter au regard des besoins et chez
moi par exemple si je prends l'exemple
alsacien on peut on doit réfléchir
territoire et on doit même réfléchir
territoire transfrontalier
je pense que les groupement hospitalier
de j'ai acheté territoriaux pourraient
avoir cette dimension je me suis inspiré
de du député thieriot dans son article
qui est à bien expliquer le système de
santé allemand qui fonctionne bien
chaque landes mais aussi en dessous des
landes des kreis et avec les villes on
constate d'abord que le coût
administratif de la santé est bien plus
faible qu'en france alors que les moyens
la santé c'est à peu près les mêmes
individuellement par habitant que parce
que le coût administratif est plus
faible parce qu'il est organisé
territorialement mais on n'a plus de
moyens à la fois pour les personnels
soignants et pour l'offre de santé trois
fois plus d irm sur un périmètre de 100
mille habitants c'est ça concrètement
l'organisation de la santé à l'allemande
joie aujourd'hui par rapport à la crise
on a envoyé des des malades à brest en
faisant plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres on a mis du on aurait pu
envoyer plus tôt à castres où c'était à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres et
finalement c'est ce qui est arrivé à
terme il ya eu aussi la des hôpitaux
allemands qui ont accueilli et qui ont
investi 20 millions d'euros pour
accueillir des professeurs d accueillir
de malades de notre territoire
si on s'était organisé à l'échelle
transfrontalière on aurait pu être
encore plus réactif à cela la crise que
nous avons vécue ici est le modèle
allemand est pour moi vraiment au modèle
exemplaire
il faut aussi pour l'organisation
sanitaire de demain décloisonner plus
fortement le médico-social et le
sanitaire et département nous pourrions
gérer complètement les ehpad et j'espère
que la loi autonomie ira dans ce sens là
il faut aussi qu'on ait une prise de
conscience du coût du service public et
du rendu du service public faut
absolument qu'on revienne à des taxes
des impôts territorialisées comment
voulez vous qu'on retrouve le
consentement à l'impôt
si nos concitoyens ne vois pas le lien
entre ce qu'ils dépensent en termes de
de 2,6 de taxes et la qualité du service
qui a rendu ça c'est à mon sens quelque
chose qui est fondamentale et mon tout
dernier point dans la perspective de la
loa 3d moi j'ai proposé au premier
ministre que la rs que les miss tour de
la rs soit déléguée à la future
collectivité européenne d'alsace qui
rassemblera les deux départements
d'abord sous forme de délégation dans
une perspective
définitif merci de votre attention merci
beaucoup je vérifie également du
caractère très propositionnelle et booth
est intéressant aussi de votre
intervention à présent et vous terminez
donc que les intervention liminaire de
nos invités
j'ai plaisir de passer la parole à jean
de kervasdoué qui vous a tous excités
qui est l'ancien directeur général des
hôpitaux emblématique s'il en fût je
peux en témoigner et qui reste
aujourd'hui un observateur et un un
acteur acérées de ces sujets genre vous
avez la parole vous et merci jean marie
ça va vous en donner sinon très bien
j'en mets alors de 2,2 deux mots de
contexte national l'autre international
c'est ce qu'on voit dans l'écran parce
que la caméra et vise bon mais je le
vois là c'est parfait merci jambes vous
écoutons donc que d'abord je suis
entièrement d'accord et toutes les
remarques qui ont été faites
merci à tous j'allais dire que c'est
étonnant comme interviendrait un
deuxième où sur le contexte leurs deux
contextes un contexte international qui
n'a pas été évoqué c'est que le monde
spécialise aujourd'hui alors que vous
n'aviez que dix spécialités médicales
maintenant 220 et on a tous vu avec que
la sphère du colline que pour certaines
prises en charge des malades lourds on
les prend que dans les grands hôpitaux
qu'il s'agisse de colmar de mulhouse
mais on les prend pas dans les petits
hôpitaux ou dans les petites cliniques
la deuxième remarque 2
taxé que vous l'avez évoqué
indirectement tous mais c'est que l'on
va rentrer dans une phase très
particulière qu'est le vieillissement de
la génération du baby boom qui commence
en 45 ans et tout ce que l'âge de la
dépendance
c'est autour de 81 3 ans donc la
génération du baby boom va rentrer en
dépendance en 2030 et on va passer de 6
millions de personnes de plus de 75 ans
alors pour comprendre la situation
actuelle
à mon avis faut faire un peu d'histoire
bref mais la première remarque c 'est
nous sommes dans une période
c'est la fin de la démocratie sociale
donc la gamme démocratie sociale qui
était inventée en 1945 a de fait à mon
avis disparu dans le domaine de la
maladie qui n'est pas le cas de la
retraite ce n'est pas le cas des
accidents du travail
mais on voit bien à part la mutualité
sociale agricole qui joue un rôle
important sur lequel on pourrait revenir
des autres pièges je ne joue plus aucun
rôle non doit-on garder tous cet
appareil très compliqué des caisses
d'assurance maladie on avis c'est une
question qu'il faut se poser
je vous rappelle que la caisse nationale
n'a été créé que en 1967
donc avant 1967 et je vais revenir il y
avait des possibilités de négocier les
tarifs
la première remarque c'est celle là la
deuxième qui plus important encore c'est
l'étatisation progressive du système de
soin donc quand vous regardez sur longue
période et pâtissier depuis un demi
siècle maintenant vous voyez que l'état
et progrès s'il veut rentrer dans la
gestion du système de soins
sans s'en donner les moyens donc on a
l'état omniprésent et un état
déliquescent
alors l'état intervient d'abord par les
statuts donc quand vous expliquer à un
étranger que le cardiologue de l'hôpital
de mulhouse il est nommé par un bureau à
paris
les côtes américaines on l'avait dit ça
marche entre dit oui mais c'est très
cher 2 par ailleurs vous avez le titre
cadres de la fonction publique donc non
j'étais à l'origine ayant travaillé avec
combien d'hôpitaux à ce moment là je
pense que ces attributs très élevé que
la gauche de l'époque à payer au parti
communiste et et je pense qu'il faut en
sortir
c'était dire je pense qu'il faut que
l'on ait des conventions collectives de
talk dans le secteur social et médico
social il n'y a absolument aucune menace
sur l'emploi national demande en france
derrière elle est complètement folle
dont il faudrait imaginer ce qui a été
fait dans les télécommunications dans
les postes c'est à dire que les gens qui
veulent garder le statut de la fonction
publique
regarde et que encore jean pas sa
déception de droit privé y compris pour
des messages
je vous rappelle que dans le système
hospitalier public français aujourd'hui
réanimateurs est payé comme un
biologiste qui travaille à lignan
haesebroeck à paris ça n'est pas
raisonnable tout ça mais pas raisonnable
donc et enfin on aille
nous avons perdu
quand on a perdu le son de monsieur de
kervasdoué nous avons perdu le sont donc
je pense les gens vous nous entendez non
plus et peut-être un problème de
connexion donc aurait coûté tant qu' on
est en train de relancer la connexion si
on arrive à le relancer tout de suite
c'est parfait si on devait rencontrer
une difficulté je commencerai race et la
parole aux sénateurs et sénatrices
inscrit j'en profite tant que la
collection n'est pas rétabli pour dire
que ce sera d'abord mathieu darnaud puis
avec gilles et puis charles guené se lia
de la faute et jean françois husson
philippe dallier
voilà les collègues qui se sont inscrits
on est déjà en dépasse 30 ans donc je ne
fais pas un appel vous êtes invention
mais bien sûr vous salue bien je le
refuse la parole à personne
est-ce que nous avons retrouvés monsieur
luc abalo et monsieur le d'or sinon je
passe tout de suite la parole la matière
nos noms nous ne l'avons pas retrouvé sa
parole à mathieu darnaud et mathieu je
sais sera souple si jamais des doigts
l'interrompt oui marché ce dernier donc
que sénateur républicain de l'ardèche et
premier vice président de la délégation
mathieu merci monsieur le président cher
jean marie et je remercie aussi
l'ensemble des intervenants du jour pour
leur propose aussi riche que passionnant
et le regard sur la crise qu'elles ont
pu avoir chacun dans leur dans leur
territoire et de façon un peu plus en
plus générale je vais être relativement
bref moi je voudrais vraiment borné mon
propos sur cette crise que nous venons
de traverser a justement certains ont
évoqué son rôle de révélateur
par rapport à des sujets que nous
mesurions déjà mais qui là se sont
révélés au grand jour de deux éléments
simplement le problème
du de laisser centralisme que beaucoup
on soulignait et qui malheureusement
notamment au tout début de la crise
s'est révélé comme un comme un frein
relativement forts notamment un exemple
pour illustrer mon propos sur la
question de l'acheminement des masques
il a fallu d'ailleurs et le divorce sur
mon département de l'ardèche que la rs
au niveau régional puisse vite prendre
le relais avec les délégations
départementales
parce que on avait quelques le sujet
était particulièrement contrariant
presque parfois en mauvais sens du terme
anecdotique et qui montre et le franc
qu'il y avait à être pour être efficace
notamment au plus proche des besoins des
acteurs et les soignants des territoires
le deuxième point là aussi et c'est pour
moi peut-être le point le le plus
fondamental c'est la question de la
coordination
notre collègue jean louis triaud l'a
évoqué tout à l'heure et moi je fais
bien c'est ses propos je ne sais pas non
plus même si j'ai une petite préférence
pour les champs département alors
référence constante dans l'agilité que
quelques jeux cet échelon permet d'avoir
de crise mais ce qui est certain c'est
que j'ai pu vivre le pire comme le
meilleur
et dès lors nous n'avons pu organiser au
niveau département de façon hebdomadaire
que ce soit au niveau de la préfecture
comme les différents arrondissements des
échanges fréquents entre parlementaires
entre maires ruraux entre la résidence
des maires du territoire ont vraiment
mettre le doigt sur les sujets qui
étaient jugés défaillants et pouvoir
ajuster de façon très pratique et avec
une démarche très pragmatique avec le
préfet qui était au centre finalement
avec la délégation départementale de
l'aer est soudainement les choses se
sont bien passées
on a pu vraiment parer aux besoins
pressant et puis trouver une espèce de
fluidité pour être aux côtés
efficacement que ce soit avec la mise en
place de centres dédiés coville que ce
soit avec un acheminement plus régulier
que ce soit la capacité à trouver aussi
des ressources sur le département sur la
question des fabrications des sciences
loose et masques donc tout c'est
finalement mieux passé dès lors on a eu
la capacité finalement à bien jauger et
jugé des besoins sur le sur le
territoire en apportant plus de
réactivité et moi vraiment je le dis et
je le pose même comme une question nous
intervenons cette question de la
coordination
parce que pour moi il faut qu'on ait de
la clarté pour un peu peut-être il
faudra pas ont peut-être définir assez
rapidement dans ces périodes de crise
qui n'aime pas le terme chef de file à
mais qui est leader dans la crise qui
coordonne l'ensemble des actions voilà
quel était mon fils merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup
cher mathieu darnaud j'ai déjà joué
d'ailleurs que de ce que nous avions
fait pendant la la crise
rappelez-vous au niveau de la délégation
en lien avec le sénat son président les
grandes associations d'élus
les douze propositions un produit scavo
déconfinement on avait mis cette
dimension de chef de file à au premier
rang quoi donc tout à fait là dessus
bien en phase alors je passe la parole à
est rigide et sénateur de la gironde
socialistes et républicains lui
demandant de brancher sa caméra et son
micro et charles des déçus près par
hervé merci monsieur le président merci
pour l'organisation de cette table ronde
elle s'inscrit aussi ou de la population
et reste avec les collectivités dans le
cadre du seigneur de la santé et de
l'élaboration de la loi 3d comme cela
elle peut souligner on a pu voir par
ailleurs que l'élaboration des projets
régionaux de santé ont souvent manqué
donc de co construction et de
concertation
un certain nombre d'entre eux d'ailleurs
ont été repoussés par les collectivités
territoriales quand elle était
sollicitée pour émettre leur avis il
faut noter d'ailleurs que dans le cadre
de ce débat il ya notre a pas eu en fait
puisque même quand le projet a été
repoussé
de toute façon c'est adapté sans
conséquence et le prs est appliquée en
tant que tel j'ai fait très sensible sur
les propos concernant la démocratie
sociale justement pour accompagner les
politiques de santé
le ps devrait en faire partie il ya
aujourd'hui des contrats locaux de santé
qui se met en place sur un certain
nombre de territoires
donc il faudrait faire en sorte que ça
ne soit pas des coquilles vides et
réintroduire de la démocratie sociale
dans l'élaboration la fois des prs et le
travail autour des contrats locaux de
santé notamment dans un aspect qui est
le rapprochement du secteur de la santé
et du médico social
ce qui revient aussi un des sujets
abordés sur la notion de chef de file a
notamment des politiques départementales
qui pourrait créer les conditions d'un
interface intelligente sur les
territoires donc c'est l'occasion
aujourd'hui vide en quête de la crise
because i ii ont visité les pratiques de
concertation les pratiques
contractuelles à l'échelle des
territoires
qu'en pensez vous qu'est-ce qui espérez
vous donc aujourd'hui d'autant plus que
quand on parle de ségur de la santé il
faut bien évidemment que les nouvelles
réponses qu'ils soient apportées soit
aussi des réponses éclairées au travers
de la gestion de crise que nous avons pu
vivre jusqu'à maintenant je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup élevé merci d'avoir été
conçue d'ailleurs je demande à nos
collègues de faire tousser tout de même
de manière à ce que nous puissions avoir
également un temps pour l' écoute des
réponses et des conclusions de nos
intervenants se passe comme prévu
quand la présence à charles guené
sénateur de la haute marne de l'aide
publique à charles et ce n'est qu'un pas
merci monsieur le président bonjour à
tous je crois que tu as fait des sites
et nos invités qui ont été assez
exhaustif dans leurs propos et ont un
peu coupé nos questions mais je vais
faire quelques remarques quand même je
voulais intervenir effectivement à
partir de la tribune
9 avril de jean louis thériault que
j'avais trouvée excellente quand il
évoquait donc efficace et a demandé aux
rapports avec des moyens mis en oeuvre
qui interpellait pour pour nous et on a
quand même l'impression que c'est pas la
ligne qui soit vraiment prise dock le
ségur de la santé à l'heure actuelle
excusez-moi de d'anticiper un petit peu
et quelque part on aimerait que vous
aviez un peu plus loin même si vous avez
été déjà vous avez un peu développé
votre propos en matière de propositions
pour l'avenir et je trouve que
d'ailleurs ou au c ur de la santé on a
un peu étonné par la place des
collectivités locales ou plutôt leur
leur absence et on est ce qu'on devra
attendre la loi 3d pour faire un une
sorte de volet phare sur le problème de
la santé et son organisation
car je crois vraiment que ce sera
l'occasion de le faire si vous pouviez
des uns des autres
développer cela serait d'ailleurs même
le président retenait rey président de
région on m'a dit que peut-être libéré
les départements donc c'est quand même
assez intéressant donc si vous pouviez
les uns et les autres encore année un
peu plus loin dans dans ces suggestions
alors simplement peut-être jamais
monsieur j'étais tout à fait d'accord
avec vous sur le corps vous avez évoqué
la territorialisation de l'impôt vous
voyez que les allemands qui sont dans le
côté conte et puis ce sont des pays
fédéraux n'ont pas d'impôts
territorialisée sont pourtant très
efficace
non je ne suis pas certain que ce soit
une bonne piste mais on pourra discuter
de ça ailleurs bien merci à tous en
attendant mais merci monsieur le vice
président de la commission des finances
du sénat
vous évoquez d'ailleurs un instant
le président de région jean refaire nous
l'avions précédemment auditionnés en
même temps d'ailleurs que lé les votre
collègue logique qui enquête également
sur les problématiques de gestion la
bucovine au niveau des collectivités
territoriales merci beaucoup je passe à
présent comme cela avait été les mots
qu'est la parole à d'autres collègues
sonia de la provôté sénatrice l'union
centriste du calvados alors que jean
françois husson et villalier sur petra
ce lien oui merci à tous pour vos
interventions qui change un peu du
discours convenu qu'on a sur la santé
depuis allez on va dire à peu près une
vingtaine d'années tranquillement et et
c'est bien d'avoir cette discussion
maintenant et probablement épisodes
qu'on a vécu plus délié les langues et
est mis en lumière les défauts moi j'ai
le sentiment quand même que depuis
quelques années il ya quand même deux
mondes qui se sont affrontés dans son
plan de la santé et que y'en a un qui a
un peu plus gagné que l'autre et ces
deux mondes c'est très caricatural mais
en le schéma il ya également de 2,2 du
papier des normes de la gestion des
chiffres du du traitement collectif de
la santé versus la santé du stéthoscope
de la parole de découpe des mains de
l'huma de l'individu et c'est très
dommageable parce que d'abord c'est
l'évolution de la façon dont on a déjà
fonctionné des choses ça a été très
justement dit par vous tous et notamment
la suralimentation et je voudrais pas
qu'on oublie la sueur admise passion
ligue nationale parce qu'on a parlé du
local on a parlé de la façon dont
l'hôpital et gérer on a parlé de la
façon dont la région est gérée avec le
péché originel et une malfaçon régional
des ars qui entraîne les graves carences
sur le terrain notamment en termes de
veille sanitaire sécurité sanitaire moi
je suis entièrement d'accord sur ce sur
ce constat mais dation administrations
nationales c'est quand même un grand
moment parce qu'entre santé publique
france
la dgs cadets jouaient cela nsm l'ansès
lâché chacun joue son rôle chacun est
indispensable chacun intervient et y'a
pas et cabinets ministériels bien sûr et
tout ça ne fonctionne pas de façon tout
à fait fluide et fusionnel va dire les
choses de cette façon on voit bien que
les décisions nationales sont aussi
prises de façon à ce qu'il ya des
tiraillements locale quand on décline
les choses on voit bien qu'il ya des
incohérences et une absence de cohésion
moi je pense qu'il ya quand même un
sujet au national aussi sur
l'organisation sanitaire et qu'il faut
qu'à un moment où on se pose la question
de s qu'il faudrait pas un petit peu
regrouper
j'en ai un peu moi et puis qu'on
clarifie les missions le sujet c'est
celui du contrôle et moi je pense que
c'est vraiment un sujet très grand on
est arrivés avant de sanitaires qui est
du protocole de la norme du budget de
quand on a un seul discours annuel
quasiment même si de temps en temps les
nouvelles sur la santé au travers du
plfss
c'est quand même c'est symptomatique
c'est symbolique
on parle de la santé au travers du
projet de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale
parce que l'équité face aux soins on y
tient sauf qu'à travers ce plfss depuis
de nombreuses années dans les choix
budgétaires
on a mis en difficulté d'équité face aux
soins d'un point de vue territorial avec
la désertification médicale mais aussi
avec les fermetures de maternités avec
avec toutes les décisions qui ont été
prises il ya aussi la question du privé
et du public qui a vraiment un conte
sujet les ars préoccupe beaucoup du
public un peu mois du privé est en tout
cas du point de vue national l'équipe et
n'a jamais été vraiment tout à fait
intégrés dans la prise en charge
sanitaire et donc moi ma ma question mon
constat qui parlera peu avec avec ce que
ce que vous avez dit roux largement de
cette aversion et de cette détestation
parce qu'on peut dire que c'est un peu
star moment et en fonction des personnes
entre ces deux mondes ce monde
gestionnaire et du papier ce monde de
tera il faudrait trouver une façon de
faire fonctionner les choses donc une
baisse de la sueur administration est
aussi accepté que la santé a un coût
parce que tout ça repose sur des
économies de santé depuis le début de a
jusqu à 7 quand on diminue les
dispositifs médicaux cdc des prothèses
de hanche son destin qu'on pose pas et
donc il faut un mouvement qu'on accepte
une augmentation de la santé qu'on dise
combien ça coûte
et quand on fait des choix qu'on soit
honnête vis-à-vis des citoyens
et ça c'est une question nationale c'est
pas qu en local que s'agir cette affaire
les besoins sont avides évaluant le
calme et le budget national est donc un
moment il faut qu'on donne les moyens
d'avoir une évaluation juste coût de la
santé et que ce ne soit pas au détriment
quitté face aux soins et au détriment de
la prise en charge sanitaire des
citoyens qui à mon sens se dégrade de
façon honnête y compris au travers de la
pénurie de médicaments c'est le même
sujet depuis plusieurs examine en merci
merci beaucoup je faisais de la provôté
donc nous avons jean de kervasdoué clés
ou ce que je propose cominoise deux
sénateurs inscrits ils vont prendre la
parole je leur demandais vraiment
safetic je sais qu'ils seront lettres et
ensuite tout de suite après je
commencerai dans les réponses par par
jean qui aura entendu qu'une partie des
interprétations bien sûr puisque il ya
eu un problème technique mais qu'il y
avait encore des choses à nous dire
puisque il était interrompue ça m'arrive
juste deux minutes pour terminer mes
recommandations parce que l essentiel
je ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai été coupé
ma femme bref je n'avais pas dray fait
c'est certainement un problème de
connexion
bon alors d'accord john carmack doué et
après lui et tous les autres
la rando minutes
bon la première chose le premier
problème dont on a assez peu parlé entre
nous c'est celui de la médecine de ville
lors la question centrale de l'hôpital à
mon avis elle est d'abord or il est donc
que je propose à tous les gouvernements
depuis au moins 20 ans d'étudier assez
sérieusement le système du paiement au
forfait annuel le système de la
capitation sachant que dans les pays où
ça marche c'est un mélange de capitation
et d'acteur je suis pas du tout pour la
généralisation de la capitation le chip
pour la proposition la qualification ce
qui me paraît plus noble de payer un
médecin pour suivre des malades que pour
entre guillemets faire des actes alors
un avantage de ce système x c'est que
saab est considérablement les
prescriptions puisque dans les pays
comme le danemark ou les pays d'europe
du nord où ça a été fait les baisses de
prescription ont été considérables et
divisé par deux il faut savoir qu'un
généraliste n'est prescrit quatre fois
ses honoraires donc si vous divisez par
deux ça fait une somme de revenus dont
je ne suis pas du tout pour l'imposer
mais je suis pour l'étudier la deuxième
chose ça a été dit elle déjà sur les
maisons de santé
la france a le talent de pervertir les
bonnes idées mais il est clair qu'avec
la consultation 24 euros les maisons de
santé ne peuvent pas fonctionner donc il
est cuit il faut étudier un système
financier et juridique permettant aux
différents problèmes de santé surtout
dans les zones rurales de travailler en
sorte d'avoir un bâtiment commun sans
que ceux-ci soient nécessairement
subventionné par les collectivités
locales
alors pour l'hôpital je suis très simple
et est assez radical
il faut que l'hôpital de vienne une
institution comme les autres
c'est-à-dire un vrai président du
conseil d'administration aujourd'hui
comme vous le savez le président du
conseil d'administration en a beaucoup
qui sont là ce matin
non en fait donc à vous c'est le
directeur qui a du pouvoir
il faut absolument qu'il ya un président
du conseil d'administration avec la
responsabilité civile et pénale qu'ils
soient nommés localement et que celui ci
nomme un directeur et nomme amène sa
chance alors la russie c'est une
particularité française
la france est un pays les hôpitaux sont
à la fois corporatistes et bureaucrates
y est corporatiste
parce que ce sont les médecins qui
élisent le président de la cme les
bureaucratique parce que c'est l'état
qui intervient tout le temps et est donc
dans tous les pays occidentaux que je
connais le médecin chef
il est nommé par le conseil
d'administration il n'est pas élu
alors qu'on aimait ça ait des intérêts
corporatistes qu'ils aient besoin de
faire valoir il ya pas de problème mais
vous voyez bien que ce système
bureaucratique et corporatistes ne
fonctionne pas donc l'hôpital c'est une
institution de droit public alors nous
avons un exemple de ça et exemple le
sens et les centres de lutte contre le
cancer
les centres de lutte contre le cancer
france sont de la propriété de l'état
est de droit privé
donc on peut tout à fait imaginer une
généralisation de ce statut là
l'essentiel
et vous avez dit madame de la provoc
avant moi c'est effectivement cette
folle nébuleuse des agences et cette
incapacité de gérer alors la
particularité alors
beaucoup plus grande que celle que vous
avez dit puisque les à georges à toutes
les agences ministère la santé
secrétaires du ministère de la santé
les nomenclatures selanne ce je ne sais
pas très bien ce que fait aujourd'hui la
neige et aux images servent à quelque
chose
mais la france est incapable de revoir
les 8000 de manque la thur d'actes
médicaux à 3 adresses quand il est parti
mais disait étudiants à la vitesse
qu'ils savent en a pour deux cents ans
alors tout ça n'est pas raisonnable
ayant fait on n'a pas parlé ensemble et
je vais terminer avec une recommandation
qui est celui de la santé mentale qui
est un sujet très très difficile et un
sujet qui va très très mal qui n'a pas
été très révélée par le crime mais
assiégée alors dans les choses donc nous
sommes tous d'accord ici qu'il faut que
ça soit gérée à l'échelon local dans
certains cas départementale dans l'autre
régional de la taille des régions a été
évoquée mais il est clair qu'on ne plus
adaptée au territoire
surtout que nous sommes héritiers d'une
très très très très long d'une soirée
unique en alsace il ya beaucoup de btu à
but non lucratif dans d'autres régions
de france y en a pas alors ya un pays
qui a un système intéressant et qui est
la sienne
c'est à dire une ya une très grande
décentralisation et les citoyens suédois
savent combien ils payent pour leur
santé il ya simplement une compensation
nationale en fonction de critères d'âge
et éventuellement de sexe et des
critères économiques nokia une quand je
disais et je vais m'arrêter là donc il
faut que les élus se rendent compte que
la démocratie sociale c'est fini et que
c'est ce jeu entre les caisses
d'assurance-maladie l'état est un jeu
coûteux qui ne sort pas et qu' il faut
que bien d'autres
duha les locales on ait la possibilité
de recruter on ne l'a pas si 8ème gérer
et on ait la possibilité de définir des
tarifs et des relations et ça c'est
possible que ce qui on a une certaine
autonomie politique et financière
merci beaucoup jean de kervasdoué donc
nous avons pu ainsi avec votre retour
entendre à la fin l'ensemble de nos
intervenants de nos invités
mais également la plupart que d'autres
collègues sénateurs et sénatrices je
crois que jean françois husson né à
connecter et ils disent ici et là alors
je passerai avant la jean françois
husson puis à philippe dallier je leur
demande évidemment d'être très
synthétique car nous sommes déjà à la
fin de notre temps et nous aimerions
entendre les réponses est évidemment de
nos invités jean françois husson
sénateur de la north et moselle les
républicains sur françois ok oui merci
président alors je sais pas si c'est le
confinement mais je trouve que le temps
du des cons film en est un tu ne le
faire bien fou j'irai sur la réflexion
et des idées j'espère que tout ça ne
ralliera pas très vite moi je voulais
aborder rapidement que je serai mieux et
vous verrez oui oui mais moi je vois
bien j'ai en même temps je regarde mon
écran je regarde public c'est là et je
regarde public sénat et je ne te voit
pas donc et tu feras tu en as vu c'est
dommage car dans basse à l'autre je vais
si je vais vérifier mais moi je pour moi
tout est bon de tests passent au suivant
tu me retrouver face à philippe dallier
je reviens vers toi c'est promis
philippe dallier sénateur de la
seine-saint-denis les républicains et en
lui demandant d'y brancher micro et
caméras a priori toutes les branches oui
c'est le président qui rassureront en
confrontant nos experts de territoire
différence est constaté que nous avons
tous vécu
même chose la lourdeur de l'organisation
actuelle s difficulté à travailler avec
les libéraux et le secteur privé à
difficulté accord de l'élection des
classes en tant qu il ya effectivement
un vrai problème qu'on a connu
exactement par sa seule un territoire ou
dans les métropoles comme ici dans la
région ile de france
ceci dit quand on a repensé une
organisation de notre système de santé
au début de cette séquence certains se
poser la question est ce que ça doit
être la région où est-ce que ça l'ouest
le département moi je te tire sa
j'attire simplement l'attention sur le
fait qu'on ne pourra pas avoir une
réponse unique à répliquer partout sur
le territoire national c'est un peu la
même chose que pour la future
organisation de collectivités
territoriales il ya certainement des
endroits dans lesquels la région sera le
territoire le plus pertinent il ya
d'autres endroits où ça peut être le
département en région ile de france et
particulièrement dans la métropole du
grand paris ça peut pas être le
département à l'évidence quand on
regarde comment le département de la
seine saint denis a été impacté par
cette crise le manque de moyens malgré
nos fêtes il est couvert par la pêche et
je ne peux pas imaginer que le fait
traiter ce département seul dans son
coin puisse être une solution
donc il va vraiment falloir penser cette
organisation en intégrant la diversité
de nos territoires
et justement en regardant quel est le
modèle le plus adapté
et effectivement la meilleure
coordination possible entre les
intercommunalités les intercommunalités
lapsus entre les collectivités
territoriales et le futur système que
nous allons mettre en place la région
département est l'un des intervenants a
même parlé de notre organisation à
l'échelle de 60000 habitants
il est bien évident que ça n'est pas
possible d'adopter un modèle comme celui
là de manière uniforme sur le territoire
donc il faut vraiment repenser sa en
tenant compte de la réalité de nos
territoires
merci fairfield alliés mais si mon cher
vice président du sénat jean françois
husson est il au souhait la caméra ça y
est
je pense que tout est bon allons-y c'est
bon voilà pardon oui donc trois
questions puisque moi je me réjouis et
je vois que tout je le redis un peu vécu
les mêmes choses et je vais l'illustré
ça parlera à tous les cas parfaitement
notre président jean marie bockel dans
la région de vente est qu'on a connue
une polémique importante avec un
directeur de l'aes un monde qui s'est
exprimé au regard de tueur et du corbeau
des remises à sion de l'hôpital est en
tous les cas d'un chu d'un chru même à
nancy en expliquant que crise ou pas le
plan laisse déroulée dans un camp puisqu
il était largement débattue donc je peux
au moment où s'ouvre le cdur de la santé
je voulais peut-être plus pour notre
grand sage recueillir son avis est ce
qu'il pense lui que entre libéré à le
changer ce qu'on avait imaginé
hier évidemment va se dérouler une
optimisation rationalisation groupe en
jeu le jeu pose quand même la question
est-ce que souvent les récompenses sur
un seul site
ça fait aussi beaucoup de concentration
la loi demande les gestes barrières les
chambres seules c'est un sujet vous
l'avez compris
deuxièmement qu'on a vécu également
finalement le raisonnement alors plus
aura décentralisée et - les services de
l'état ce grand bol finalement plus qui
travaillent en silo puisqu'on a vu grâce
à ces deux réunions avec les
parlementaires sous l'autorité du préfet
de département que finalement il y avait
d'un côté la rs qui vivait sa vie et de
l'autre le préfet qu'il est la sienne
avec le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
assez peu d'articulation est ce que il
n'est pas temps finalement de
réorganiser les choses c'est à dire une
véritable articulations une
transversalité premièrement moi j'ose
vous dire mes chers collègues que je
crois que même le débat 3d à mon avis
doit être fondamentalement repensées et
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin c'est
sûrement une occasion je pense l'unique
enfin dernier dernier sujet beaucoup de
critiques ont été entendues au droit de
la loi hpst
c'était très bien départ monsieur pierru
je trouve avec des formules qui marque
pensez vous que la grèce telle qu'elle
avait été imaginé puis à 12 ans est-ce
qu'il n'est pas temps de la voir
s'organiser déférence que juste je
voudrais permis n'est pas là il ya un
nombre pour moi impressionnant de
collaborateurs dont les adresses ça
dépasse pour moi l'entendement et on a
bien vu dans cette crise qui avait des
ch'tis voilà c'est des questions gère
que je vous adresse collectivement merci
mecs qui vous couvre en france ovules
sont à présent l'ensemble de nos
collègues ont pu être entendus exulte et
je propose à nos cinq intervenants de
conclure cette table ronde on a pris un
peu de retard mais comme c'est
passionnant on en est malgré tout très
très heureux les finances vraiment et je
vous ferai des petits messages veiller
au grain de conclure chacun en cinq
minutes et nous allons reprendre leur
route à l'heure monsieur le député vous
avez été attentif et patient pendant ces
groupes que vous avez introducteur cher
jean louis thiériot vous avez la parole
conclusion réponse merci merci merci
monsieur le président d'abord je salue
finalement l'unanimité des constats qui
ont été qui ont été partagés je crois
qu'on peut retenir quatre éléments le
premier essai ce que disait très bien
monsieur pierru
la question n'est pas que la question
des ars on peut pas en faire un bouc
émissaire c'est l'ensemble de
l'architecturé de notre système de santé
qui doit être repensée c'est notamment
sa bureaucratisation il ya un chiffre
que j'avais cité dans cet article que
vous avez eu la gentillesse d'évoquer 34
% de personnels administratifs au sens
large dans le système hospitalier
français entre 21 et 22 % en allemagne
la différence ça ferait cent mille
soigneur de plus au contact des malades
un impératif la coordination est arrêté
travailler en tuyaux d'orgue et je salue
mon collègue maire rural j'étais maire
d'une commune de 207 habitants
donc je mesure ce que ça représente en
plus confié
et pour prendre un exemple de tuyaux
d'orgue j'ai vu la difficulté de faire
travailler pendant cette crise du coc
vide
ensemble les médecins rouge et les
médecins blanc parce que faire
travailler ensemble des médecins
pompiers et des médecins sa mue cet
étonnant on a l'impression que la nato
nice change selon la couleur des camions
donc oui coordination absolument
indispensable conséquence de cette
coordination la nécessité d'un chef de
file a vraiment efficace on l'a évoqué
dans différents domaines sur le sujet
des ehpad
quand vous avez la rs d'un côté qui
s'occupe du soin le département de
l'hébergement et vous y ajoutez parfois
un troisième élément qui sont les
syndicats de communes qui porte le
projet collectif avec un directeur sur
lequel aucun des présidents de conseil
d'administration non d'autorité vous
arrivez au chaos et au cas que j'ai eu
dans mon territoire ou une directrice
nommée par les restes recrutait
tellement de contractuels que ça sortait
du budget pour éviter que le budget soit
faussée on oubliait tout simplement de
faire les déclarations urssaf
je vous laisse imaginer les conséquences
donc un exemple qui doit aboutir un chef
de file à très clair sur le
médico-social et le médical est
effectivement adaptée au territoire ça
ne peut pas être la même chose partout
mais je pense que le département sauf
cas particulier est le meilleur pour le
faire eu égard à sa dimension c'est pas
vrai partout et on peut très bien
envisager pour le médico social
je ne sais plus lequel de mes collègues
sénateurs évoqué le nombre de personnel
dans les ars ça s'est fait au moment de
la
on des directions départementales de
l'équipement en grande partie de ces
personnels sont passés entre les mains
des départements ça peut être une
manière de centraliser vraiment un chef
de file à départementale
enfin je finirai par sa la nécessité de
souplesse et de capacités
d'expérimentation et de
territorialisation des mesures la
télémédecine on souffre tous dans nos
deux déserts médicaux le mal qu'on a eu
à pouvoir le mettre en place pour des
raisons réglementaires dans un certain
nombre de cas le sujet des maisons
médicales qu'on n'arrive pas à ouvrir
parce qu'il faut au minimum deux
médecins qui évoquait nos collègues
maires on doit avoir de la
simplification je pense qu'on ne doit
pas avoir peur d'être très audacieux sur
ce sujet ce que jean de kervasdoué
disait très justement sur le fait qu'on
doit considérer le médico social comme
rendons un service particulier mais
ayant finalement des statuts très proche
d'un régime dans certains cas priver
quitte à ce que ce soit des fonds d'état
ou des fonds départementaux le but c'est
la souplesse ce sont des conventions
collectives et c'est la seule manière de
coller aux besoins des territoires donc
des habitants donc de garder le sens de
la mission
parce que c'est ça qu'on a tous en tête
le sens de la mission qui nous a motivés
à j merci beaucoup
cherruault louis thiériot de ses propos
pragmatique et à mon avis
que quelqu'un veut que quelqu'un qui est
son micro a mis les voiles et bien mais
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît couper
vos micros
merci jean luc hees était vraiment fort
intéressant merci monsieur le député
d'avoir été là tout de suite je passe la
parole avec le même souci de concision
bien sûr à dominique que du move au
maire de s'axer sur ce tas et vice
président des maires ruraux de france
2010 oui bah écoutez je vais essayer
d'être le plus complet possible et
essayer d'aborder quelques sujets qui
les quelques jeux sur quelques apporter
quelques réponses par à quelques
questions qui est en cours ont été
posées par pas à vos collègues
tout d'abord je doute donc que la loi 3d
puisse régler ses solutions de de
compétences j'en doute vraiment je doute
d'ailleurs quelques haleine jusqu'au
bout et donc je préfère ne pas l'appuyer
sur cette espérance pour voir changer
les choses sur le ségur de la santé on
voit bien que le gouvernement a fait le
choix de traiter tout d'abord là le
sujet des hôpitaux
ce qui est à mon avis une erreur
stratégique et est lourde de
conséquences demain évidemment l'accès
aux soins dans nos territoires est une
des clés pour répondre aux difficultés
de fonctionnement de deux hôpitaux on a
des urgences engorgées qu'ils ne sont la
plupart du temps parce que la médecine
de ville n'est pas en capacité de
répondre aux sollicitations de jose
administrés parce que la plupart du
temps les médecins sont de moins en
moins en capacité d'accueillir de
nouveaux patients et donc il me semble
indispensable que ce c'est dur ça tu es
intègre ce sujet la dent dans ces débats
et puisse apporter des solutions à nos
territoires en termes de solutions que
vous peut que l'on peut imaginer demain
on a bien vu que en situation de crise
nos administrés s'étaient emparés de la
téléconsultation alors qu'on avait de
nombreuses réticences auparavant et nous
sommes nous convaincu mais ruraux que
sur quelques sujets bien précis
évidemment de la téléconsultation peut
être une des pistes pour des hangars
désengorger les salles d'attentes et
permettre à nos administrés d'avoir des
d'aidé à l'accès aux soins plus simple
en très ancienne dans vos attentes
au cours des infirmières assure des
permanences dans des dents dans des
lieux dans des pharmacies dans des
maisons de retraite pour leur permettre
justement de pouvoir très rapidement et
de manière assez simple pouvoir avoir un
médecin
en fait dans un écran comme nous faisons
aujourd'hui avec cet échange et on se
rend bien compte que malgré tout à
partir du moment où les dans un acte
médical unités c'est tout à fait
pertinent de mettre en oeuvre et il
faudrait les ars pour tout cela avant
subit plus garder quelques quelques
mises quelques outils ont été mis en
place durant cette crise pour permettre
à ces téléconsultations de fonctionner
demain parce qu'aujourd'hui on se
rendait bien compte que avant la crise
il était très difficile d'obtenir
qu'arriver à qui a fonctionné ce type de
2,2 d'outils parce que les restrictions
et elle n'y arrivions pas et que souvent
les mères abandonnées les intérieurs les
autres alors qu'il en avait l'énergie et
l'envié et parfois même des financements
n'est que les rs bloqué derrière un
sujet qui a été à peu abordé qu'il me
sens moi essentiel c'est nos aînés on a
eu la canicule de 2003 avec avec de
nombreux morts et ça nous a pas servi de
leçon et on a continué à les accueillir
dans des lieux pas forcément toujours à
capter et cette crise a encore montré
que de les ehpad et hélas avait joué un
grand rôle dans ce temps dans dans ce
drame dans ce drame et cammas felipe
était en grande partie au moins pour
pour un tiers dans les ehpad et il me
semble essentiel de réfléchir demain
comment pouvoir accueillir nos aînés
d'une manière différente et notre
association l'association des maires
ruraux c'est une des îles ou avril
positionné pour réfléchir à un nouveau
modèle pour accueillir les aînés on voit
que beaucoup de nos aînés quittent nos
villages pour aller dans des ehpad ou
pour aller dans des villes parce que
parce que leur habitation n'est pas
adapté pour les laisser vieillir dans de
bonnes conditions dans l'eure à leur
domicile et nous pensions que la
solution serait certainement à de
démultiplier les modèles type béguinage
pour leur permettre de rester naulleau
commune pour leur permettre d'être dans
des dents dans des logements adaptés au
vieillissement et et pour aussi éviter
dommage de nous
une crise devait se nous tomber sur la
tête
être en capacité de donner de les
accueillir de les accompagner alors
qu'aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans une
situation humaine très difficile donc je
pense que ce serait aussi une des clés
pour que notre société puisse avoir
cette résilience et qu'elle puisse yeux
de ne pas avoir honte de la manière dont
elle traite nos ennemis aujourd'hui
voilà un tollé les quelques sujets qui
me semblait important de bronze merci
infiniment
chez le public du mot de votre présence
et votre opposition avec cette
sensibilité du monde rural qui est
importante pour nous particulièrement
aux au sénat qui sommes à mantoue grand
- sur le bon équilibre des territoires y
compris sur ces questions je pense à
présent la parole à ceneri que pierru
donc qui est l'universitaire qui porte
un regard non pas d'acteur mais
l'observateur à céret à la fois sur
cette problématique est aussi surtout
des changes frédéric toujours dans cet
esprit de synthèse des conclusions nous
vous écoutons bien merci monsieur le
président oui je vais faire très court
en vous écoutant je revisite et un peu
d'histoire des débats autour de la
gouvernance du système de santé
j'ai été entendus alors je ne serai plus
là qui en a parlé réclamé en fait de
talent et vers une décentralisation du
système de santé alors il se trouve que
ce fut une option qui a été explorée au
milieu des années 80 et je tiens quand
même à le rappeler c'est que les élus
locaux n'ont pas voulu c'est à dire que
si l'êta a repris la main c'est aussi
parce que les élus locaux ont préféré je
dirais plutôt dans un rôle
d'influenceurs du préfet selon un schéma
classique tue préfet et ses élus plutôt
que de supporter la responsabilité
excusez-moi de je vais vous citer une
expression mais que j'avais vu chez les
élus locaux s'étaient décentraliser la
santé s'est décentralisé les emmerdes
l'expression mais il y avait cette idée
qui va aller mieux
en quelque sorte joué un rôle
d'influenceurs aux frais des autorités
étatiques plutôt que de supporter la
responsabilité politique du pilotage de
sociales de santé il me semble que
l'option de la décentralisation me
paraît très difficile aujourd'hui étant
donné d'abord ce qui a été mis en place
depuis le puits des années et puis quand
même ça pose des problèmes redoutable
dans un contexte de déséquilibres
territoriaux croissant 1 et 2 et de
richesses notamment entre les
territoires donc je pense que sur un
enjeu aussi sensible que la santé ou les
inégalités d'accès aux soins sont les
inégalités les plus mal tolérées par le
corps social
je pense que d'aller vers une option
d'une balkanisation décentralisatrice me
semblerait assez compliqué et d'ailleurs
les pays qui ont décentraliser je pense
à l'espagne par exemple on en fait une
expérience amère alors il me semble que
l'option de la déconcentration et de
l'unification je vais m'expliquer et
plus des plus probable est à mon avis
plus souhaitable alors unification comme
l'a dit jean de kervasdoué je pense
qu'il va falloir lever les ambiguïtés
gedik hpst c'était un armistice
institutionnelles entre la cnam le
ministère et les préfets et là on voit
bien qu'on est allé au bout d'un système
bancal 1 où chacun finalement garde son
pré carré donc je pense qu'effectivement
il va falloir réfléchir à l'unification
à mettre fin à la dyarchie assurance
maladie est un c'est à dire assurance
maladie qui régule la médecine libérale
l'état qui se charge de l'hôpital parce
que on parle du ségur de la santé je
suis désolé de dire que le secteur de la
santé dans ses murs de l'hôpital ça
n'est pas en ses murs de la santé on y
parle que de l'hôpital est en fait c'est
un dispositif que je peux comprendre sur
le plan politique qui sert à de tra
lisez la contestation spital hier
jusqu'à l'été bon en tout cas c'est
comme ça que je le vois
et puis donc unifier les tutelles au
niveau national ici et clarifier un
c'est 14 de nordhorn je vais pas revenir
sur le conseil national de pilotage est
ainsi ubuesque des agences régionales de
santé au niveau du ministère et puis
aller vers la déconcentration alors
effectivement je pense que on voit bien
que la logique y ait compte consistait à
centraliser au maximum les décisions au
niveau des sièges régionaux donc
des grandes régions n'est plus
praticable donc effectivement soin de
trouver un échelon praticable de
proximité d'une part c'est à dire les
départements ou même infra
départementale en dotant par exemple en
redéployant les délégations
départementales et en leur donnant un
vrai pouvoir
et puis bien sûr en articulant cela avec
alors qu'il va falloir déréglé aussi le
problème des conflits entre les dg ars
lé préfet c'est à dire est ce que l'on
met un seul chef et que les âges et les
agressent reviennent dans le giron des
préfets c'est possible c'est c'est
envisageable en tout cas il va falloir
trancher ou l' inverse
et puis et puis associés évidemment les
élus locaux le plus le plus étroitement
possible à ces structures de proximité
voilà donc effectivement l'option de la
décentralisation me paraît très peu
envie d'elle
voilà merci merci beaucoup
frédéric pierru je retiens une phrase
est ce que nous avons nous avons débuté
en ce moment un c ur de l'hôpital où est
ce que
nous gardons l'objectif de ségur de la
santé moi j'aimerais bien qu'on est
assez lieu la santé parce que comme
cette table ronde le monde le montre
bien tout ça cela se tient et ça ne se
tient également dans l'esprit dans les
attentes légitimes de nos concitoyens
affaire à suivre
merci frédéric que berry nous vous
écoutons monsieur le président du
conseil départemental du pas de calais
votre conclusion
merci merci jean marie alors j'ai tout
de suite d'abord réagir aux propos de
monsieur pierru dans sa première
intervention je partage et 95% de ces
propos là je suis un petit peu dans une
vision un peu différente
alors c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
peut-être nous avions manqué abandonné
de maturité les élus pour prendre cette
responsabilité en charge de la santé bon
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est en
capacité de faire là où les territoires
le souhaite je pense qu'il faut pouvoir
expérimenter une véritable
décentralisation du volet santé et
médico social et social qui doit à mes
yeux être décloisonner alors bien
évidemment aux as raison quand vous
parlez de barback balkanisation
décentralisatrice je crois qu'il peut
s'assurer bien évidemment que pour
l'ensemble des concitoyens du territoire
national en garantissent un niveau de
santé équitable
ça a été évoqué d'ailleurs par d'autres
sénateurs qui parler d'équité
territoriale et c'est là où on peut
attendre l'engagement de l'état là où
effectivement après avoir plus de
difficultés à mettre en oeuvre une
politique de santé adaptées que au titre
dans une démarche de péréquation et de
dévaluation et de soutien l'état puisse
compenser les difficultés que les
collectivités pourraient rencontrer pour
faire face à cet enjeu
bien évidemment je partage par contre
cette idée de renforcer la
déconcentration je pense que là la
sphère publique avec une part
décentraliser une part des concentrés on
travaille en bonne intelligence
pourrait répondre à l'enjeu d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure quand je crois que
c'était mathieu darnaud hook évoqué
l'enjeu de la coordination de crise je
les ai vus alors nalsace ou ou vraiment
on a été au coeur malheureusement de la
crise due qu'au guide quand on avait un
travail en bonne intelligence préfet
présente département et président des
maires du territoire
on a été en capacité d'avoir des
réponses agile et réactive chacun chacun
à sa place mais il y avait une vraie un
vrai il ya de qualité qui a été
organisée à ce moment là et c'est
quelque chose que je pense qu'il faut
prévoir sur des situations de crise
nouvelles auxquelles on pourrait être
confrontée j'avais d'ailleurs dit au
premier ministre cette sphère publique
territoriale co-organisé déconcentrées
et décentralisées
c'est celle là qui a du sens et j'aurais
voulu d'ailleurs quand on avait évoqué
des zones rouges des zones vertes qu'on
tienne compte de cette capacité ratio
publique territoriale de s'organiser
pour faire les bons choix en terme
d'organisation des confits demandé qu'on
finisse je voulais dire aussi je crois
que c'était régime et qui parlait de la
réintroduire la démocratie sociale de la
santé en ce cas des belles expériences
autour des contrats locaux de santé
médico-sociaux et sociaux c'est à dire
un vrai constat de terrain les à
l'échelle de vie de nos concitoyens et
et à partir de ces constats des carences
sanitaires mais aussi des potentiels
sanitaires on doit pouvoir faire des
propositions qui ont du sens où les
acteurs locaux doivent être engagées moi
je vois chez moi dans l'intercommunalité
où j'étais mère celle à
l'intercommunalité qui avaient acheté
des locaux pour accueillir une clinique
donc il ya une vraie prise de conscience
de la réalité d'un engagement local mais
avec du coup la nécessité la par rapport
à nos points de différence avec charles
guené même si on en a on a beaucoup de
points de convergence on avait un point
de différence sur sur l'impôt si on veut
avec nos quotidiens accepte que la santé
un coup il faut leur montrer le coupez
la en proximité
si vous les expliquer
le coût d'une clinique à un habitant qui
profitent des services de cette clinique
il est plus à même d'accepter l'impôt ou
le couple que ça peut générer que si on
parle de sommes colossales à l'échelle
nationale qui ne lui parle pas je pense
qu'il ya quand même un enjeu à
travailler sur cet élément
sonia de la provôté évoqué la sueur
qualité administrative j'ai eu
l'occasion des représentants de cet
athée ou frédéric parce que tu le
deuxième à présent de gavage doué à
ammal prononcer le nom de sonia de la
provôté précise mais tu n'y es pour rien
mais qu'on présente la délégation je me
tiendrai moi je vous prie de m'excuser
vous avez évoqué la sueur qualité
administrative
je crois que c'est un vrai problème de
notre de notre fonctionnement
administratif et est aujourd'hui il ya
j'avais eu l'occasion de dire au
président de la république
1200 agences d'état ça coûte 60
milliards à notre pays et là on a un
exemple sur la santé qui a été évoqué
tout à l'heure sur la multiplicité des
acteurs qui du coup empêche toute
fluidité et là il ya en déconcentrant et
décentralisant l'action sanitaire sur
les territoires on s'éviterait toutes
ses dépenses administratives et sur le
déficit des kits et sanitaires que vous
évoquez il ya 7 ans j'ai eu
effectivement que l'état soit garant
c'est là où elle a un rôle à jouer
garant d'une offre de santé de qualité
sur l'ensemble des territoires mais
quand on démarre par une confiance qu'on
peut témoigner au territoire et c'est
seulement et si et seulement le
territoire est en difficulté que l'état
doit aux capacités de d'agir
jean françois husson a évoqué
articulations et transversalité avec la
loi 3d j'espère j'espère que la loi 3d
permettra dé l expérimentation sur sur
des territoires qui sont prêts à
s'engager
j'ai parfois
peur mais c'est pas propre à ce
gouvernement mais tous les gouvernements
qui se sont succédé ont souvent parler
de décentralisation mais ils ont souvent
fait semblant faire de la
décentralisation
donc je crois que la différenciation
aujourd'hui au regard des situations
diverses de notre territoire
ça peut être une façon de faire avancer
la qualité de l'action publique sur dans
notre pays
j'espère que l'on fera pas semblant de
faire une loi
voilà c'est ça c'est mon le voeu que je
voulais former et à philippe dallier
dans la suite logique de mes propos il
n'y a pas de réponse unique
territoriales je partage complètement
sans son analyse et c'est là aussi où la
loi 3d pourrait avoir une une bonne
expression
et puis terminer sur les propos de
monsieur du monde sur le béguinage
je crois aussi au regard des besoins de
nos aînés qu'il faut permettre de faire
évoluer le droit du travail sur les
accueillants familiaux j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de dire au ministre de la
santé qui se sont succédé dans le
travail aussi de la préparation de la
loi autonomie je crois qu'il faut qu'on
puisse déployer plus fortement tout ce
qui est mannequin domicile ça suppose
aussi une revalorisation de tous ces
métiers qui aujourd'hui manqué de
considération de ces délits que berry en
le remerciant de sa présence et de ces
paroles fortes qu'eux
ce que vous dites les uns les autres j
avais fait allusion dans mon
introduction doivent bien sûr nourrir la
réflexion gouvernementale sur la future
loi 3d mais doit de notre point de vue
d'abord nourrir la réflexion du sénat
puisque nous nous sommes engagés à
l'initiative du président larcher et
nous sommes ici la délégation pleinement
associés à cette démarche à des
proposition sénatoriale sur ce que
devrait être la poursuite de la
décentralisation et donc aussi de la
déconcentration et ce travail devait
aboutir au niveau du sénat gérard
larcher l'a encore rappelé que cette
semaine tout de suite après des
municipales à une travaillons d'ailleurs
d'ici là s'en sort la semaine à la
semaine et c'est un travail auquel
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des groupes du cdh
à son associé même si bien sûr in fine
et la majorité sénatoriale fera ses
propositions sous l'autorité de notre
président deux ans que ça va être pour
le gouvernement qui pour le moment n'a
pas encore véritablement de loi 3d je le
sais parce que jacques riou a étant un
bon dialogue avec nous nous lavons
auditionné en développement notamment
sur les meltones de nous serons sur des
propositions qui viendra nourrir cette
méthode ce que vous dites ça nourrit a
notamment sur le retour d'expérience
ceux de salt endémie et la manière dont
il a vécu en france nos propositions et
donc cette solution même à cet égard
elle est intéressante et je veux redire
elle a son importance merci en tout cas
et se passe à présent la parole pour son
mot de la fin qui sera le dernier à jean
de kervasdoué en demandant aux
collectionneurs qui le peuvent de rester
ensuite encore quelques minutes avec
nous car nous avons un autre point à
l'ordre du jour chercheur car à jouer
vous avez le mot de la fin
merci merci merci monsieur le président
a remercié amharique oui alors je
raccroche beaucoup de choses a été dit
et je partage ce qu'a dit notamment
frédéric c'est à dire je ne pense pas
que nous sommes prêts on peut le
regretter à avoir une vraie
décentralisation mais en revanche nous
sommes tous d'accord pour à mon avis
deux choses la première
c'est collé aux territoires s'adapter à
la réalité locale d'une part et d'autre
part avoir un état qui fonctionne alors
collé aux territoires en français dans
le texte
ça veut dire pouvoir recruter pouvoir
innover pouvoir contracter et pouvoir
payer l'année très très loin aujourd'hui
parce qu'on ne peut pas recruter en
dehors de ça qu on ne peut pas innover
redore des nomenclatures et est
aujourd'hui pour faire entrer d'un acte
dans la nomenclature par exemple il faut
au moins cinq ans donc ça c'est le
premier le premier aspect donc jusqu'où
peut-on aller dans cette liberté là vous
évoquiez la difficulté payer les nerfs
familial et donc et c'est tout ça ça
veut dire statut national
deuxièmement avoir un état qui
fonctionne alors une des conséquences de
la sphère du sang contaminé a été que
les gouvernants n'ont plus voulu avoir
en direct la responsabilité des agences
est en fait pour le dire assez
simplement les agents sont en roue libre
les passent leur vie à ouvrir le
parapluie
parce que nous avons une particularité
française que vous connaissez
probablement probablement pas c'est que
nous sommes le seul pays occidental
avons une responsabilité civile et
pénale des fonctionnaires
en angleterre il ya ni responsabilité
civile me responsabilités pénales
les responsables donc moment là faire de
la vache folle ils ont infiltré un
certain nombre de fonctionnaires mais
voilà il n'y a pas eu de procès et aux
états unis à seulement une
responsabilité civile et donc vous voyez
bien que c'est sûr protection et ses
normes folle qui sont imposés à tous
elles viennent en partie de là et je
terminerai
un sujet qui n'a pas été ok qui est la
compétence ou les compétences au sein de
8,7 à chanter l'entrée curieusement le
ministre de la santé se caractérise par
le fait qu'il a très peu de médecins et
que les les experts du ministère de la
santé sont surtout des experts
juridiques ou administratifs donc le
directeur zonal la santé quelqu'un de
tout à fait respectable un compresseur
de chantiers publics ça toujours été un
professeur de médecine mais en dessous
de l'huile expertise en santé publique
est très très absente et on a bien vu
par tout ce que vous avez dit les uns
les autres c'est ta capacité de mener
opérationnellement la gestion des
masques mais on aurait pu également
parlé de la gestion des tests enfin je
sais pas si vous avez remarqué que une
des raisons pour lesquelles on a eu peu
de tests pcr alors qu'il ya des machines
c'est que les machines étaient dans les
services vétérinaires
nous avons d'excellents services
vétérinaires que les vétérinaires sont
très très bons en virologie
mais qu'il a fallu un mois et demi avant
pour trouver le bon texte le décret pour
autoriser les délais vétérinaire faire
des tâches pcr on peut continuer dans
l'ensemble de ses actionnaires et
administratives donc on a une scheer
détermination et protectrice de l'état
et des fonctionnaires pas de
responsabilités politiques sur les
agences et enfin tous attendent en plus
une sur vous tous et notamment sur les
plus loin du centre et je pense aux
communes rurales avec en fait comment
dirais-je une aliénation parce qu'on
voit les problèmes on est incapable de
bien pâles donc donc et ça ça veut dire
quand même pour remettre en cause
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de nos
pratiques et qu'on aille un peu plus
loin que les symptômes et qu'on remonte
aux causes
merci cher jean de kervasdoué pour ce
regard
à la fois de sart expérimenté mais ce
regard aussi à la fois pointue et tourné
vers le monde qui vient
et de ce point de vue là je trouve que
nos intervenants ont été tous à la fois
intéressant très complémentaires face à
des sénateurs et sénatrices ce qui vous
l'avez compris étaient également sur
bull est également force de proposition
sur ce sujet donc visiblement nous
aurons à reparler
merci beaucoup ces deux tables rondes de
quêter en direct sur public sénat sur le
site du sénat se termine je remercie
d'ailleurs je les remercie de l'avoir
diffusé en direct et je demande aux
sénateurs tout en saluant dans
intervenants mais je m'échauffe traque
aux attentes mais je les salue
je demande un essai d'affaires de rester
parmi nous à l'ordre du jour qui paient
normalement devrait également être suivi
par le site du sénat et qui concerne le
cette table ronde sur les élus locaux et
des agences régionales de santé pour
faire le bilan sur leur coordination
pendant la crise sanitaire je vous
propose maintenant de suivre une
audition de l' agence de sûreté
nucléaire devant les sénateurs l' agence
de sûreté nucléaire présente son rapport
annuel sur la sécurité des centrales
nucléaires en france
je vous laisse écouter cette audition
nous sommes en situation mixte puisqu'il
y à la fois partie de collègues présents
je les félicite mais je remercie
également ceux qui ont accepté de
participer de par le système numérique à
à cette réunion de l'office pour
permettre justement sa tenue car nous
n'aurions pas pu fonctionner en plein
effectif dans cette salle médicis alors
à l'ordre du jour
nous avons question majeure c'est le
rapport annuel pour 2019 de l'autorité
de sûreté nucléaire qui va nous être
présentée par le président de l'asn
bernard doroszczuk et son directeur
général olivier gupta je salue l'un et
l'autre et le remercie de leur présence
je voudrais naturellement ça devait
cédric villani premier vice-président et
qui représente ici l'assemblée et saluer
l'ensemble des collègues présents ou
connecté et dire aux membres du collège
de l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui ne
peuvent pas participer mais qui suivent
j'en suis certain cette union toute la
sympathie et l'estiment que ce leur
travail procure et suscite chez mes
collègues parlementaires je salue madame
cadets mercier madame evrard ainsi que
messieurs chômé riffaud et la chaume
voilà alors c'est la deuxième fois cher
président que nous vous entendons cette
audition est liée à la loi du 13 juin
2006 que bruno sido et moi-même
connaissons bien puisque elle a en
partie réglé les problèmes de la
sécurité en matière nucléaire la
transparence et la réactualisation de la
loi de décembre 91 sur la gestion des
déchets nucléaires
et cette loi du 13 juin 2006 prévoit la
présentation du rapport annuel de l'asn
devant notre fils dont il est vrai que
notre fils a une histoire et nous en
avons en bénéficient ont bénéficié des
travaux n'a l'historien du cdrs je crois
il ya quelques mois de cela
une histoire qui est extrêmement liée au
dés à volonté du parlement
de mieux faire connaître nos
compatriotes
le travail de la filière
électronucléaire en général et de la
sécurité nucléaire en particulier alors
vous étiez venu en mai 2019 et vous
aviez avec avec beaucoup de de sérénité
mais détermination sonne l alarme sur la
nécessité d'un ressaisissement la
filière nucléaire pour le maintien des
compétences industrielles problème
majeur problème compétences
industrielles nécessaires à la qualité
des réalisations et à la sûreté des
installations
et c'est assez d'occasions cette séance
du 16 mai 2019 que vous étiez intervenus
avec beaucoup de clarté et sur la
question qui est toujours pendante mais
qui évolue je crois favorablement des
soudures de le p r de flamanville les
soudures de ce réseau principal
secondaire ou secondaire principal c'est
cette fin un raccourci un petit peu
surprenant mais enfin on a bien compris
que c'était à la fois important mais que
ce n'était pas cette tête de l'eau
chaude sous pression mais qui n'était
pas elle théoriquement contaminés à
nucléarisé en quelque sorte
nous avons d'ailleurs dans le sillage de
cette réunion du 16 mai le 17 juillet
organisé une table ronde publique assez
et assez vivante où les gens se sont dit
les choses avec beaucoup de politesse
mais beaucoup de 2,2 de rigueur
intellectuelle ce qui est plutôt
satisfaisant puisque nous avions votre
présence naturellement celle de l'ifsn
des représentants d'associations
impliquées dans le le suivi de la
sécurité nucléaire et naturellement les
deux grands acteurs que sont à la fois
edf directement impliqués et or anneaux
aujourd'hui je crois que les une
évolution qui est engagée ce que vous
nous en parlerez et je suis convaincu en
tout état de cause c'est ma certitude
absolue que la condition du nucléaire
c'est la transparence et que tout ce qui
contribue et parfaitement bienvenue même
si on peut à tel ou tel moment déranger
des certitudes
guînes qui ne seraient pas suffisamment
consolidée vous allez nous dire j'en
suis persuadé dans votre intervention ce
qui s'est passé depuis
vous avez une année 2010 9 qui est
extrêmement riche puisque vous avez
commencé leur examen des réacteurs de
900 mégawatts nous avait suivi
naturellement et madame emilie cariou
malheureusement n'est pas avec nous ce
matin
l'avancement
du célèbre png mdr programme national de
gestion des déchets matières
radioactives et jeux pour le programme
débat sur lequel vous jouez pour lequel
vous avez joué un rôle essentiel et
naturellement je suis certain que vous
insisterait sur l'engagement des
procédures de démantèlement la réflexion
sur fessenheim est arrêté ou encore
démanteler la commence pas du tout enfin
les travaux n'ont pas commencé mais ont
ils sont des jeux dès maintenant
programmée donc nous avons un ordre du
jour extrêmement extrêmement riche
ce qui fait je vais parler moins
longtemps mais je tiens c'était la
parole à cédric villani nous a rejoints
dans cette salle médicis du sénat et son
intervention à la fois comme
parlementaire comme scientifique on le
connaît son lot de mon coeur intéresse
les l'ensemble des membres de l'office
présent est connecté merci monsieur le
président monsieur président de au souk
se faire général gupta directeur général
pardon bienvenue dans ce dans cette
salle ce sera la treizième fois
aujourd'hui que nous entendrons les
représentants de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire à l'occasion de la
présentation de leur rapport annuel sur
l'état de la sûreté nucléaire et de la
radioprotection
treizième fois conformément à la loi du
13 juin 2006 relative à la transparence
et à la sécurité en matière de nucléaire
que nous avons ce rendez vous le
président longue et evo qui les quelques
instants l'importance capitale la
transparence dans ce sujet si sensible
qu'il le nucléaire un sujet qui a été
d'ailleurs à l'origine de la naissance
de l'office parlementaire scientifique
dans les années 80 même si le fils et
depuis bien sûr beaucoup diversifié dans
ses intérêts et cet exercice de
transparence devant la représentation
nationale
on a vu à plusieurs reprises à quel
point c'était important le président
longué longué évoqué tout à l'heure
cette séance au cours de laquelle était
présente dès est furano il irait scène
on pourrait dire
avec un jeu de mots facile qu'il avait
de l'électricité dans l'air c'était pour
la bonne cause qu'il y avait à une
dialectique disons assez vives sur les
questions de sécurité en particulier
relatives à ce dossier de le p r
flamanville et tous et tous ces sujets
ces sujets de qui intéressent à la fois
la question de la souveraineté en
matière d'énergie mais aussi la question
de la sécurité la question de
l'information et de la nation nous les
renvoyons à chaque fois qu'il le faut
dans un souci de transparence et de
responsabilité
je remercie pour leur participation les
collègues commissaires de du président
et du directeur général
je parle de sylvie cadets mercier lydie
evrard philippe chaume et riffaud jean
luc lachaume et les messages que je vais
retenir de votre dernière intervention
sont majeurs l'un concernait la question
de l'anticipation des enjeux de sécurité
de radioprotection dans un domaine où le
temps long et crée et met un temps
incroyablement long on se retrouve à
avoir des dossiers qui couvrent des
décennies sinon des siècles
et s'il s'agit de parler de la
décroissance de l'activité des déchets
nucléaires
on retrouve sur ordre de grandeur encore
bien plus grand désordre qui les ordres
de grandeur qui défie l'imagination et
qui nous amène non seulement dans le
domaine scientifique mais dans le
domaine éthique nous avions un second
message majeur sur la question du
maintien des marges pour la sûreté dans
un contexte où on a trop souvent
l'inclinaison de d'aller au plus
efficaces au plus serré et où il y as
besoin bien sûr de marge
le troisième message concernait le
renforcement des compétences au sein de
la filière nous avons vu au cours
dernières auditions systématiquement
s'inviter des problèmes qu'ils n'étaient
pas des problèmes scientifiques ni des
problèmes technologiques ou bien des
problèmes de mise en oeuvre des
problèmes d'ingénierie des problèmes
d'industrialisation des problèmes de
savoir faire et à coup sûr cette
question va s'inviter serez invités dans
nos débats
monsieur le
président nous comptons sur vous pour un
exposé clair précis et sans fard de la
situation de la sûreté et de la
radioprotection
au cours de l'année écoulée et
l'avancement notamment de ce fameux
chantier du réacteur nucléaire de
flamanville dont nous avons déjà parlé
nous serions aussi intéressé à vous
entendre sur la crise sanitaire les
répercussions que cela a pu avoir sur
votre fonctionnement toutes les
réflexions que cela a pu vous inspirer
nous avons déjà eu l'occasion d'évoquer
cela lors d'une audition récente de
lierre sn consacré aux incendies dans la
région de tchernobyl et nous avions
constaté entendu toute la fierté de la
rsm d'avoir réussi à maintenir toute sa
qualité de service au travers de cette
crise
c'est important pour toutes les
institutions que d'arriver à faire face
quelles que soient les circonstances
surtout pour des questions aussi
sensibles aussi crucial que le nucléaire
monsieur le président à vous la parole
le président monsieur le vice président
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
merci de m'accueillir aujourd'hui avec
olivier gupta pour vous présenter le
rapport annuel de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire au titre de l'année 2010 9 ma
présentation s'articulera autour d'un
constat général d'une appréciation des
résultats obtenus par les exploitants et
dans les domaines différents domaines
d'activité puis du rappel de quelques
faits marquants
compte tenu du contexte si vous le
permettez monsieur le président monsieur
vice président je terminerai mon
intervention par quelques éléments liés
à la gestion de la situation pandémique
que 8,19 tout d'abord un constat général
l'asn estime que le niveau de sûreté et
de radioprotection dans les
installations et les activités
nucléaires a été acceptable en 2019 avec
des points positifs que je soulignerai
mais aussi des points qui nécessite des
améliorations plusieurs pointes
positives peuvent appuyer ce constat
général
tout d'abord dans le domaine nucléaire
aucun incident majeur n'est affecté les
installations en service et aucun rejet
significatifs dans l'environnement n'a
été constatée en 2010 9 l'année 2019 a
été marquée par une plus grande prise de
conscience par les exploitants
nucléaires des défis auxquels ils sont
confrontés
collectivement notamment en termes de
renforcement des compétences et de la
qualité des réalisations
cette prise de conscience s'est appuyé
sur les positions répétées de l'asn mais
aussi sur les conclusions du rapport
falls et sur les réflexions collectives
engagé par la filière au sein du gie
feng les mesures engagées par les
exploitants suite à la découverte de
fraudes ont permis de progresser
les analyses des exploitants et les
investigations menées par l'asn sur les
quelques cas avérés n'ont pas mis en
évidence de risque pour la sûreté
la sûreté des transports de substances
radioactives s'est maintenue à un niveau
satisfaisant au regard du nombre
d'opérations effectuées et les résultats
obtenus en matière de radioprotection
dans le domaine industriel sont
acceptables même si une vigilance plus
forte encore être portée aux activités
de gammagraphie réalisés sur les
chantiers enfin dans le domaine médical
le nombre d'événements significatifs de
radioprotection déclaré par les
professionnels de santé et demeurait
très faible en 2019 au regard du nombre
d'actes réalisés sur les patients et de
la complexité de certains de ces actes
derrière ces constats généraux qui vont
dans le bon sens
il faut souligner des nuances entre
exploitants nucléaires et entre
disciplines médicales et des points à
améliorer
chez edf tout d'abord malgré des
résultats de sûreté globalement
satisfaisant deux points de vigilance
sont apparus en 2019
la saturation des capacités d'ingénierie
et le recul de la rigueur d'exploitation
ces dernières années edf a engagé des
modifications ambitieuses de ses
installations dans le cadre des réexamen
périodique des réacteurs en 2019
edf a réalisé dans des conditions
satisfaisantes
la première quatrième visite décennale
d'un de ses réacteurs de 900 mégawatts
sur le site de tricastin
pour réussir cette opération edf a
mobilisé des moyens importants
d'ingénérie tant au niveau central qu'au
niveau du site pour concevoir ces
améliorations et accompagner leur
première mise en oeuvre sur le terrain
ce qui était indispensable mais l'asm
constate de plus en plus une saturation
des capacités d'ingénierie d'edf et
s'interroge sur sa capacité à mobiliser
de tels moyens à l'avenir sur les autres
réacteurs et donc à assurer avec succès
dans des plannings réalistes les
réexamens de sûreté par la revue des
constats qu'elle a effectués
l'asn considère que la rigueur
d'exploitation des centrales nucléaires
d'edf est en recul en 2019
trois constats peuvent illustrer cette
appréciation
tout d'abord 3 nm
les événements significatifs ont été
classés au niveau 2 en 2019 sur le parc
nucléaire d'edf
contre zéro en 2018 deux d'entre eux
mettent en évidence des gestes et des
décisions inadaptées des intervenants et
le franchissement de ligne de défense en
matière de sûreté comme par exemple sur
les sites de golfech et de penly
ensuite chaque année l'asn réalise des
mises en situation des équipes d'edf
à l'occasion de ces inspections les
mises en situation réalisé en 2019 par
exemple la simulation d'un départ de feu
une inondation interne ou un rejet de
liquides dangereux ont démontré que la
documentation opérationnel d'edf
n'étaient pas toujours adaptés à la
réalité du terrain et qu'elle contenait
des erreurs voire d instruction
impossible à exécuter
compte tenu de la configuration des
installations enfin si edf a davantage
privilégié la remise en conformité
rapide de son installation après
détection d'un écart l'année 2019 encore
été marquée par la détection de
non-conformité résultant de la mise en
oeuvre deux modifications y compris
récemment ou d'une maintenance
insuffisante malgré des progrès
indéniables qu'il y a donc chez edf
un effort à faire pour renforcer la
rigueur d'exploitation qui fait appel à
la compétence et à la conscience
professionnelle des intervenants chez
aura nos cycles l'asn estime que le
niveau de sûreté des installations est
demeuré à un niveau satisfaisant en 2019
le groupe aura nos amis en place une
nouvelle organisation plus centralisée
mais s'appuyant sur les structures
dédiées sur site ce qui a permis
d'améliorer la qualité des réexamen
périodique et de mieux maîtriser les
risques de vieillissement des
installations aura le cycle a achevé en
2019 la construction de la quasi
totalité des moyens complémentaires de
sûreté issus des évaluations réalisées à
l'itie de l'accident de fukushima
pour anne au cycle est en avance sur ce
point par rapport aux autres exploitants
nucléaires par exemple l'ensemble des
nouveaux moyens destinés à faire feu
face à des situations extrêmes comme de
nouveaux bâtiments de crise
robuste ou des moyens d'appoint d'eau
complémentaires ont été mises en place
deux points peuvent encore cependant
faire l'objet d'une vigilance de la part
de renault
tout d'abord la surveillance des
prestataires notamment ceux chargés des
contrôles et des essais périodiques qui
reste à améliorer
et ensuite la maîtrise des projets liés
à la reprise des déchets anciens et au
démantèlement qui connaissent des
reports parfois pour des dizaines
d'années des échéances définies par au
radeau en 2019 l'asn a engagé avec aura
nos une démarche de contrôle de gestion
des projets avec l'appui de la dgec qui
sera poursuivie en 2020 puis étendue
progressivement aux autres exploitants
dans la même situation
enfin en ce qui concerne le cea l'asn
considère que la sûreté des
installations est restée globalement
satisfaisante en 2019
malgré un contexte budgétaire
préoccupant et les retards significatifs
dans la mise en oeuvre de certaines
mesures post fukushima
l'évolution de l'organisation mise en
oeuvre au second semestre 2010 9 sur le
chantier du réacteur jules horowitz
à karrada un cadrage pardon est
globalement satisfaisante mais les
enjeux principaux pour le cea porte sur
la poursuite de fonctionnement
d'installation conçu suivant des
standards de sûreté anciens aujourd'hui
largement dépassé ainsi que sur le
démantèlement des installations et la
gestion des déchets historiques près de
40 installations du domaine
civilo-militaires du ceva sont
définitivement arrêtées ou en
démantèlement en 2019 l'asn et
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire de
défense la snd ont examiné la nouvelle
stratégie de démantèlement élaboré par
le cea
l'asn et la snd ont confirmé la
pertinence général un moyen constant
alloués par l'état de cette stratégie et
de la priorisation réalisés notamment
sur les sites de marcoule et de saclay
même si la réduction des risques
présentés par ses anciennes
installations ne sera pas effective
avant au mieux une dizaine d'années
l'asn et la snd on attirait l'attention
du premier ministre
sur le fait qu'un effort
d'investissement spécifique et le
renforcement des équipes de sûreté dédié
à ces projets leur paraissait nécessaire
voilà les différentes appréciations pour
ce qui concerne les principaux
exploitants nucléaires hors
installations de stockage des déchets de
l'endroit qui ont dans le niveau de
sûreté est resté satisfaisant en 2019
les dernières nuance que je voudrais
souligner dans le bilan 2010 9 concerne
les disciplines médicales utilisant les
rayonnements ionisants aux
radiothérapies les fondamentaux de la
sécurité sont en place et les démarches
qualité progresse en curiethérapie la
sécurité des soins la radioprotection
des professionnels et la gestion des
sources scellées de haute activité sont
globalement satisfaisantes
en revanche dans le domaine des
pratiques interventionnelle radioguidés
l'asn estime que les mesures qu'elle
préconise depuis plusieurs années ne
sont toujours pas suffisamment prises en
compte pour améliorer la radioprotection
des patients et des professionnels
notamment pour les actes de chirurgie
réalisés dans les blocs opératoires des
écarts réglementaires sont fréquemment
relevées en inspection et des événements
sont régulièrement déclarés à l'asn en
raison de dépassements des limites de
dose délivrée chez les praticiens
interventionnelle l'état la
radioprotection est nettement meilleure
dans les services qu'ils utilisent cette
technique depuis longtemps par exemple
dans les services d'imagerie où sont
réalisées des activités de cardiologie
ou de neurologie interventionnelle des
progrès sont donc possibles pour la
scène la formation continue des
professionnels et l'intervention de
physiciens médicaux constitue
probablement les deux points clés pour
garantir la maîtrise des doses délivrées
lors des actes interventionnelle j'aurai
terminé la présentation de ce rapport
2019 en soulignant trois faits marquants
de l'année écoulée
tout d'abord et comme vous l'avez
rappelé en 2019 l'asn a été amené à
prendre une décision lourde d'imposer la
réparation des soudures défectueuses sur
les traversées enceintes des circuits
secondaires
le père de flamanville
l'asn a considéré que la nature et le
nombre particulièrement important des
cars survenue lors de la conception et
de la fabrication du circuit constitué
un obstacle majeur pour maintien en
l'état de ses soudures trois scénarios
de réparation des soudures ont été
étudiés par edf sur lesquels l'asn a
fait part de son analyse préliminaire
des risques et des points sensibles en
octobre 2019 edf a retenu en priorité un
scénario de réparation par l'intérieur
des traversées ce qui nécessite le
développement de moyens particuliers
d'intervention et ce qui est en cours la
qualification des procédés est en cours
avec une fin de travaux de réparation
envisagée à ce stade par edf au second
semestre
2021 et l'asn est en contact régulier
avec edf poursuite poursuivre par dont
l'élaboration de ces qualifications
par ailleurs au vu des investigations
supplémentaires
menés par edf à la demande de l'asn sur
l'ensemble des lignes vapeur et des
circuits d'alimentation en eau c'est une
centaine de soudure qui devront être
réparées avant la mise en service de le
prd soudure qui sont plus accessibles
que les soudures de traverser ans un
autre fait marquant de 2010 neuf
concernent la protection des centrales
nucléaires face aux risques naturels
l'année 2019 a été marquée par plusieurs
épisodes caniculaires et par le séisme
du teil survenu le 11 novembre 2019
en période de canicule et de sécheresse
les exploitants doivent veiller au bon
fonctionnement des systèmes de sûreté à
la capacité de refroidissement du
réacteur et à la maîtrise des rejets qui
peuvent être affectées par les
températures élevées de l'air ou de
l'eau ou par les débit trop faible dans
les cours d'eau lors des épisodes
caniculaires de 2019 l'asn a été amené à
l'edf pardon été amené à arrêter
plusieurs réacteurs et réduire la
puissance de certains autres l'asn n'a
pas relevé d'écart par rapport aux
consignes à respecter
néanmoins face à la répétition de ces
événements l'asn a demandé à edf de
définir un nouveau référentiel grand
chaud
à prendre en compte lors des réexamens
de sûreté de tous les réacteurs pour
anticiper les effets du réchauffement
climatique
un autre événement 2019 est liée aux
risques naturels concerne le séisme le
niveau de séismes pris en compte dans la
démonstration de sûreté découle d'un
séisme historique relevé dans la zone
géographique dans laquelle se trouvent
les centrales nucléaires mais ce niveau
de séismes doit être réévalué par edf
périodiquement lors des réexamens ou
lors d'un événement nouveau qui se
produit dans l'intervalle c'est ce qui
s'est produit en 2019 avec le cynisme et
du teil dans le niveau atteint est
apparu très proche du niveau historique
pris en compte dans la démonstration de
sûreté l'asn a demandé à edf de
déterminer si ce séisme devait conduire
à réévaluer le niveau de séismes auquel
les centrale nucléaire de tricastin et
de cruas de doit pouvoir faire face
cette analyse est en cours et la sn
prendra position sur ce sujet en 2020 le
dernier fait marquant que je
souhaiterais évoqué concerne
l'élaboration du plan national de
gestion des matières et des déchets
radioactifs dont vous avez parlé
monsieur le président la préparation du
prochain plan a en effet fait l'objet
pour la première fois d'un débat public
préalable organisé en 2019 par la
commission nationale du débat public le
débat public s'est déroulée du 17 avril
au 25 septembre la commission nationale
du débat public et la commission
particulière du débat public ont
présenté les conclusions qu'elle tire de
ce débat le 25 novembre le ministre de
la transition écologique et solidaire et
l'asn ont communiqué le 21 février 2020
les suites qu'elle envisage de donner au
débat
je me limiterai à n'en citer
quelques-unes pour illustrer les thèmes
prioritaires qui ont émergé des débats
tout d'abord une meilleure articulation
sera recherchée entre politique
énergétique et politique de gestion des
déchets et la gouvernance du plan sera
renforcée par exemple la périodicité
d'élaboration du pngmdr sera mise en
cohérence avec la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie ce qui n'est
pas le cas actuellement et
l'articulation du plan avec les
stratégies d'arrêt définitif et de
démantèlement des industriels sera mieux
explicités dans le plan pour répondre
aux attentes en matière de gouvernance
le fonctionnement de l'instance
d'élaboration et de suivi du plan sera
clarifiée et cette instance sera élargie
à des représentants des parlementaires
de la société civile et aux
représentants des collectivités locales
pour répondre aux besoins désormais
urgent le pngmdr prévoir à la mise en
oeuvre de nouvelles capacités
d'entreposage des combustibles usés en
tenant compte de l'avis rendu en 2019
par l'asn sur les options de sûreté du
projet de piscine d'entreposage
centralisée par présenté par edf
le plan prévoirait en complément l'étude
des conditions et les situations dans
lesquelles un entreposage à sec des
combustibles usés pourrait être utile le
gouvernement fera évoluer le cadre
réglementaire applicable à la gestion
des déchets de très faible activité afin
d'introduire une nouvelle possibilité de
dérogation ciblées permettant une
valorisation au cas par cas des déchets
radioactifs métalliques de très faible
activité
après fusion et des contaminations le
pngmdr formulera des recommandations
quant aux modalités de mise en oeuvre de
telles dérogations en prenant en
considération les travaux menés à la
demande de l'opex par le haut comité
pour la transparence et l'information
sur la sécurité nucléaire
enfin le plan précisera les conditions
de mise en oeuvre de la réversibilité du
stockage des déchets à haute activité
vie longue
en particulier en matière de
récupérabilité des colis et poursuivra
la définition des modalités
d'association duplique aux étape
structurante du projet cigéo la
rédaction du 5ème plan et son évaluation
environnementale stratégique ées la
consultation du public ont pas lieu au
début de l'année 2000 21 et le projet de
plan sera ensuite rendues publiques
étranges transmis à le texte
voilà monsieur le président est monsieur
le vice-président les points du rapport
annuel que je souhaitais souhaité
souligner pour finir et avant de passer
la parole à olivier gupta je compléterai
brièvement aux propos par quelques
éléments liés à la gestion de la
situation épidémique actuel avec la
crise couve it 19 l'industrie
la filière nucléaire est confronté pour
la première fois de cette liste de son
histoire à une crise sans que l'origine
non soi une cause liée à son activité
durant la période de confinement seules
les centrales nucléaires d'edf et les
activités nécessaires au fonctionnement
de ses centrales en termes
d'approvisionnement de combustible et d'
équilibre du cycle combustibles ont été
maintenus en service les enjeux de
sûreté pendant la période de confinement
ont donc concerner de mi mars à mi avril
un nombre limité d'installation et un
nombre très réduit d'exploitants priori
deux exploitants edf et ruano le
contrôle des installations nucléaires en
exploitation s'est poursuivie sous des
formes adaptées et cette adaptation a
été similaire dans tous les pays du
clara pour faire face à cette épidémie
temps les exploitants que l'asn ont
actionné leur plan de continuité
d'activité dont il dispose
en cas de pandémie grippale
l'application de ces plans n'a pas posé
de difficultés particulières
la réduction du nombre de personnels et
de prestataires spécialisés présents sur
des sites a conduit à la réduction
importante des activités chez l'ensemble
des exploitants et edf a été obligés de
prolonger les arrêts de tranche et de
décaler les arrêts de tranche
ces décalages ont eu des incidences sur
le respect de certaines échéances
réglementaires ayant conduit l'asn à
instruire des demandes ponctuelles de
dérogation qui n'ont pour l'instant
pas soulever de difficultés depuis le 11
mai les activités nucléaires reprennent
progressivement dans les prochains mois
les reports cumulé des arrêts de tranche
et edf et le rythme encore réduit des
travaux à réaliser vont imposer une
reprogrammation substantielle des arrêts
par effet domino cette reprogrammation
va largement débordé sur 2021 et sur
2022 voire au delà
cette situation quand je y aura des
effets de sûreté et de sécurité
d'alimentation électrique
la stratégie envisagée par edf à ce
stade consiste principalement à des cars
les l'arrêt de certains réacteurs
pour lisser les effets sur la
disponibilité du parc ou à envisager un
sourd d'arrêt pour les réacteurs
disposant encore de suffisamment de
combustible pour fonctionner pendant
l'hiver prochain contrairement à
d'autres pays
je pense notamment aux états unis edf
n'a pas prévu de réduire
significativement son volume de travaux
de maintenance et de modification
pendant les arrêts réacteurs les arrêts
sont décalés mais le le contenu des
travaux à réaliser des opérations de
contrôle est maintenue pour chacun de
ses arrêts cette stratégie est favorable
à la sûreté à ce stade l'asn estime que
l'analyse réalisée par edf a été menée
suivant des hypothèses réalistes
du point de vue industriel et prudente
du point de vue de la sûreté
les écarts identifié au regard des
échéances réglementaires de sûreté
peuvent être prêtés dans le cadre de
processus connu et déjà mis en oeuvre
par le passé par des f par snc décalage
de quelques semaines pour la plupart des
cas ou de quelques mois dans un nombre
limité de situation ont conduit à
identifier à ce stade une dizaine de
situations qui nécessiteront des
autorisations de l'asn
d'ici la fin de l'année 2020 ou au début
de l'année 2000 21 maintenu à ce niveau
la démarche d'edf est acceptable un
point de vigilance particulier devra
être maintenue par edf néanmoins sur les
visites décennales des réacteurs
qui sont des arrêts à plus fort enjeu ce
point fera l'objet d'un examen
approfondi entre l'asn et edf
voilà ce que je souhaitais indiqué
monsieur le président monsieur le
vice-président en termes de présentation
du rapport et en termes d'information
sur le contexte actuel que nous vivons
depuis le début de cette année et si
vous le permettez je passe la parole à
olivier guitta pour vous parler de la
manière dont nous avons exercé notre
contrôle dans un contexte inédit à la
fois en 2019 mais six ans depuis le
début de cette année merci monsieur le
président monsieur vice-présidente dames
et messieurs les parlementaires
effectivement ce rendez vous annuel est
aussi pour nous l'occasion de vous
rendre compte de la manière dont nous
exerçons nos missions et sur ce point il
ya une question qui a pu se faire jour
depuis que nous avons nous mêmes
d'ailleurs alerté sur la situation
difficile de la filière nucléaire c'est
que faisons-nous asn face à cette
situation et s'y est ajouté ces
dernières semaines naturellement une
autre question vous l'avait relayé
monsieur le vice président sait comment
réagit l'asn
face à la crise sanitaire que nous
traversons avec dans les deux cas un
certain nombre de questions sur la
quantité des contrôles alors avant même
de parler de quantité il est important
de bien focalisé les contrôles sur les
sujets importants et c'est là notre
premier travail si je puis dire c'est de
porter un diagnostic de la situation et
d'en apprécier tous les enjeux nous
faisons sur la base de nos inspections
de l'analyse des incidents du dialogue
soutenu et continue que nous avons avec
les parties prenantes et les industriels
et c'est cette évaluation que le
président de l'asn vient de vous
présenter cette évaluation ce diagnostic
nous voulons le plus impartiale possible
et le statut que vous nous avez donné
par la loi est clairement un atout pour
cela et une fois ce diagnostic posé
c'est seulement une fois qu'il est posée
que nous pouvons effectivement faire en
sorte d'orienter notre contrôle là où il
faut et notre action vise à faire en
sorte finalement que les industriels
focalisent leurs moyens sur les sujets
où nous estimons qu'ils doivent
progresser
jeudi les industriels parce que ce sont
d'abord eux qui ont les leviers entre
les mains ce sont eux qui sont les
premiers responsables de la sûreté et
quand on parle de redressement de la
filière nucléaire
naturellement c'est d'abord parce que
les choses vont passer nous avons nous
mêmes un levier pour cela c'est que
finalement quand nous contrôlons quand
nous posons des questions aux uns et aux
autres finalement nous focalisons leurs
moyens enfin nous contribuons du moins à
focaliser leurs moyens sur les sujets
que nous estimons important
je prends l'exemple de la qualité des
réalisations bernard derosier indiqué
que c'était un honneur une de nos
préoccupations en 2019
mais pour cela il faut que les
intervenants soient formés c'est une
chose que nous vérifions à deux niveaux
au niveau stratégique
nous analysons les politiques de
formation la gestion des compétences
chez les différents exploitants et en
particulier et df avec ces dernières
années d'efforts renouvellement de
compétences et puis sur le terrain nous
accentuerons la pression de contrôle
comme nous savons que c'est un sujet
délicat nous accentuons la pression de
contrôle sur ce point en vérifiant les
qualifications des intervenants en sus
en surveillant en vérifiant les
conditions d'intervention et à tout ce
qui concourt finalement à la maîtrise
des gestes techniques de la même manière
lorsque nous plaçons un site nucléaire
sous surveillance renforcée ça a été le
cas en 2019 du site
enfin de la centrale flamanville 1 2
l'objectif est d'abord de vérifier que
l'exploitant a lui-même fait un bon
diagnostic de la situation et s'est doté
d'un plan d'action qui répondent aux
différentes difficultés et fragilité qui
ont été identifiés et c'est cela que
nous surveillons de manière renforcée
l'avancement de ce plan d'action est
bonne réalisation des actions et
finalement c'est un petit peu la même
chose
la même chose pour la crise sanitaire
kovy 19
nous avons commencé par identifier les
enjeux spécifiques de cette crise qui a
été une situation naturellement
complètement nouvelle pour l'ensemble
des acteurs pour vérifier que les
exploitants ont bien identifié les
points de fragilité et ont pris les
bonnes orientations
la bonne mesure des actions à mener en
matière de sûreté et donc ces dernières
semaines nous avons focalisé notre
contrôle sur ses potentiels points de
fragilité
que ce soit en termes de sûreté par
exemple est-ce que les opérations de
maintenance importante continue bien
d'être programme est réalisé
est-ce qu'elles le sont dans de bonnes
conditions de sûreté
est-ce que la surveillance des
prestataires et bien réalisé ça c'est le
côté sûreté et puis comme sommes aussi
en charge en termes d'inspection du
travail sur les centrales nucléaires
est ce que les plans de prévention des
entreprises intervenantes tiennent
compte de la situation sanitaire que le
19è ce que les gestes barrières sur les
chantiers sont bien appliquées voilà
quelques exemples de sujets sur lesquels
nous avons focalisé notre contrôle et
donc sur lesquels finalement nous avons
poussé les exploitants à faire plus
attention et donc au total face à la
situation que traverse la filière
nucléaire
nous ne sommes pas tant dans l'idée du
quantitatif du plus de contrôles que du
qualitatif d'adapter les contrôles sur
les sujets en jeu pour si je puis
utilisé ces termes appuyer là où ça fait
mal et faire progresser les industriels
sur les sujets où ils le doivent
j'ai illustré cette méthode avec des
exemples pris dans le domaine du gros
nucléaire mais c'est exactement la même
chose dans le domaine du nucléaire de
proximité et du nucléaire médical alors
tout ça naturellement nécessite que nos
inspecteurs dispose de compétences
adaptées et nous avons plusieurs actions
de gestion interne pour développer la
compétence et l'expérience cumulée et en
particulier la durée totale de postes de
nos personnels au sein de l'asn ou dans
les secteurs du contrôle j'ajoute et je
terminerai là dessus que nos modalités
de contrôle nos exigences en matière de
sûreté nucléaire et de radioprotection
nous les calibres on avait avec celles
de nos homologues étrangers c'est le
principe aux homologues étrangers en
particulier européens pour à la fois
tenir compte naturellement des
spécificités françaises parce qu'il y a
des spécificités
des spécificités françaises donc devons
tenir compte par exemple le caractère
très standardisée du parc nucléaire qui
est unique au monde
mais aussi naturellement nous souhaitons
nous inscrire dans les meilleures
pratiques internationales et nous
souhaitons aussi contribué à les définir
voilà je pourrais vous en parler plus
longuement si vous avez des questions
sur ce point je vous remercie de votre
attention
oui merci de nom et c'est nous qui vous
remercions de votre intervention de
votre travail et de cet engagement
prolongé poursuivre maintenir et adapter
la mission de contrôle et de sécurité
dans ce contexte mais là je voudrais
revenir sur le contexte spécifique de
l'épée libye mucovie 19
vous avez évoqué le président qu'au fond
c'est elle une crise extérieure au monde
nucléaire mais qui s'imposait à lui
d'abord pour vous pour l'asn en interne
vous l'avez évoqué comment avez vous
géré vous vos effectifs et la façon de
d'intervenir de vaud inspecteurs en
particulier ce que vous avez été
confronté à une perte de moyens une
diminution moyens dans les très
concrètement alors dès l annonce du
confinement nous avons placé l'ensemble
de nos personnels en travail à distance
donc chacun de travailler depuis chez
soi mais finalement pour l'essentiel
tout ce qui est travail d'instruction
analyse de dossiers qui ce qui se fait
sur document finalement a pu se
poursuivre j'allais dire pour
l'essentiel de façon quasi nominal alors
je dis quasi nominal est pas totalement
nominal parce que naturellement il ya
une déperdition liée au fait que nous
avons aussi certains personnels qui se
trouvait avec garde d'enfants et donc
qu'on veut on sait bien que le temps
disponible n'est naturellement pas tout
à fait le même
mais si je prends l'exemple des
du sujet extrêmement important de la
préparation de notre position de fin
d'année sur la poursuite d'exploitation
des réacteurs de 900 mégawatts cette
position générique
nous avons tenu plusieurs préparer et
tenu plusieurs séances du collège des
commissaires dans cette période donc
avec tout un travail préparatoire au
niveau des services qui s'est déroulée à
peu près au même rythme qu'il aurait été
en situation normale donc nous avons
effectivement sur ce volet-là continuer
à un rythme soutenu notre activité et
c'était extrêmement important de le
faire
l'adaptation la plus majeur si je puis
dire que nous avons eue elle a concerné
les inspections puisque nous avons
décidé au moment du confinement de
suspendre les inspections sur site alors
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que
l'activité finalement sur site sur
certains sites en tout cas beaucoup
diminuer toutes les installations faire
beaucoup d'installations pas tout à fait
tout mais beaucoup d'installations du
cycle du combustible
et naturellement des installations de
recherche ont fermé tout simplement ont
cessé leur activité
et puis même celles qui ont continué en
particulier les centrales nucléaires ont
vu leur activité baisser
il ya eu beaucoup moins d'interventions
de notamment de prestataires nos
sociétés prestataires pour la
maintenance tout ça a été étalée sur sur
un temps plus long donc l'intensité de
travaux était moindre et il n'était pas
illégitime du coup de s'y rendre moins
fréquemment typiquement rythme normal on
y va une fois tous les quinze jours sur
les sur une centrale nucléaire donner
une fois tous les quinze jours
là on aura laissé passé un mois et demi
en gros sont y aller et ensuite on y re
venu une fois que les conditions d'une
part nous permet notamment
sanitaire enfin disponibilité de gel
hydroalcoolique de masques etc ont été
retrouvés pour nous pour nos personnels
mais aussi parce que finalement nous
avons mis en place un contrôle à
distance qui nous a permis finalement de
suivre assez précisément est assez
efficacement quelle était la situation
des installations quand je parle de
contrôle à distance
enfin il même d'inspection à distance
quand on fait une inspection sur site
ça commence souvent par une réunion en
salle avec l'exploitant on épluche des
dossiers et on pose des questions en
salle et en fait quand je parle
d'inspection à 10 ans passer typiquement
des choses qu'on a pu faire à distance
on s'est fait transmettre ces documents
on les a épluché a distancé ensuite on a
fait des visioconférences ou des
téléconférences pour poser les questions
et on n'a pas perdu
c'est à dire presque au contraire en
efficacité sur ce point après on a
identifié qu'il y avait naturellement
des choses qu'on ne pouvait voir que sur
site et c'est pour ça qu'à partir de la
mi avril
nous y sommes revenus et il ya eu pour
être précis sur la période de 2 mois 1
15 mars 15 mai donc plutôt en fin de
période naturellement 18 inspections sur
site
12 au titre de la sûreté et 6e titre de
l'inspection du travail qui au fond nous
ont permis de confirmer que ce qu'on
avait vu à distance était bien la
réalité des choses est que en
particulier sur les questions
donc comme je veux enfin point que j'ai
évoqué là
mon propos liminaires sur la
programmation des interventions
maintenance sur la surveillance des
prestataires sur les conditions
d'intervention des prestataires les
choses avaient été faites comme il le
fallait je poursuis d'interrogations sur
les conséquences pratiques et peut-être
positive cette expérience de télé
travail de réorganisation contraintes du
travail d'inspection
est-ce que cela vous conduit à vous dire
tiens après tout on pourrait faire les
choses différemment
oui c'est c'est tout à fait ce que nous
sommes en train d'examiner
tout d'abord nous avons pu mettre
l'ensemble du personnel en travail à
distance et réalisées ces contrôles ou
inspection à distance parce que nous
disposions à la fois d'équipement et
d'une infrastructure informatique et le
permettait et donc il ya eu une
condition favorable à ce travail qui
n'existait peut-être pas dans tous les
services de l'état mais qui était rendu
qui était présente à la scène et ça
c'est un point important en terme de
précautions pour pouvoir faire face à ce
type de situation c'est l'équipement
dont nous disposons et l' usage
l'application de ces deux de ses
équipements ensuite nous avons pendant
toute la période de d'organisation du
contrôle à distance
constamment cela a été dit tout à
l'heure échanger avec nos homologues
étrangers pour voir comment eux mêmes
faisait face à cette situation et
qu'elle pratique il développé et nous
avons pu organiser nos contrôles et
notre inspection à distance en tirant le
retour d'expérience de ce qui se passait
à l'étranger et ça s'est passé de la
même manière dans tous les pays
nucléarisés c'est un prix important
ensuite nous avons trouvé un bénéfice
lorsque nous sommes revenus ça vient
d'âtre indiqué sur site pour vérifier un
certain nombre de points
nous avons vu tout l'apport positif qu
avait été celui du travail à distance et
notamment nous avons développé des
méthodes qui n'existaient pas
précédemment grâce à des liaisons
numériques direct avec les exploitants
nous avons pu contrôler quasiment en
temps réel
un certain nombre de paramètres
d'exploitation que nous ne pouvions pas
voir bien évidemment lorsque nous étions
en situation d'inspection une fois tous
les quinze jours sur les sites
nucléaires et donc nous avons appris à
travers cette pratique de contrôle à
distance à travers ces échanges
organisés avec nos homologues à
l'étranger
nous avons appris tout le bénéfice dont
on que nous pouvions tirer de cette de
cette méthode de contrôle et notre
intention est bien évidemment à l'avenir
d'organiser nos contrôles de telle
manière à ce que nous puissions marier
les deux approches à la fois à distance
et sur six est un élément aussi qui
était qui était important dans notre
approche de contrôle à distance c'est
que sur les centrales nucléaires et
c'est un cas particulier
nous sommes à la fois inspecteurs de la
sûreté de la radioprotection et
inspecteur du travail et donc nous avons
pu à travers ses méthodes à la fois de
contrôle et d'inspection à distance puis
de vérification sur site puisque depuis
début mai nous avons repris des
inspections sur site ciblé notamment sur
la période de sur les conditions de
gestion de la situation des betemit nous
avons pu marié de manière intégrée une
approche de contrôle sur la sûreté et
sur les conditions de travail ce qui
n'est pas le cas pour les autres
exploitants nucléaires nous ne devrons
pas cette responsabilité d'inspection du
travail
donc nous tirons toute une série de
retours d'expérience de la manière dont
nous sommes organisés à la fois en
termes de doughty d'inspection et de
contrôle en termes d' approche intégrée
de contrôle qui doivent être exploitées
à l'avenir
sur les conséquences de ce pour vous et
pour l'exploitant edf s il y à des
retards significatifs inévitable qui
peuvent avoir des conséquences des
rendez vous fixés qui sont
nécessairement porter vous avez vous
avez évoqué un glissement dans le temps
qui est bien au delà des deux 2 mois
perdus qui n'ont pas été complètement
perdus mais est-ce qui est ce qu'il y a
des rendez vous par exemple sur le
justement sur les contrôles de 900
mégawatts sur les quarante ans qui qui
qui pourrait être remis sur une période
longue et qui serait une cause de de
problème est peut-être une deuxième
question
alors qui est plus technique celle là
est ce que le fonctionnement des
centrales nucléaires liée à la
diminution de la consommation électrique
à la part plus importante
proportionnellement du renouvelable et
en partie et par voie de conséquence à
une exigence de flexibilité plus grande
des centrales nucléaires conduits ces
centrales anciennes gérer d'une façon
plus flexible a présenté peut-être plus
de fatigue plus de vieillissement
donc deux questions et y at il des
rendez vous importants reporter et
lingots nos comportements des centrales
en madame préville merci pour votre
présentation moi j'avais quelques
petites questions sur des choses que
vous avez mentionné d'abord alors sur le
père de flamanville vous avez parlé
d'une centaine de soudure plus
facilement accessibles est-ce qu'elles
seront alors je ne sais pas si on dirait
paraît est-ce que elles seront réparés
simultanément ou d'ores et déjà ou est
ce que c'est un plan qui interviendra
après et qui devrait provoquer donc un
retard encore plus important ensuite
vous avez parlé d'un référentiel grand
chaud pour les centrales nucléaires
comment est-ce qu'on se situe par
rapport aux limites sur les débits des
rivières qui servent au refroidissement
est ce qu'on voit déjà arriver peut-être
quelque chose qui qui serait fort
préjudiciable à leur fonctionnement et
enfin sur les événements donc il ya vous
avez mentionné trois événements de
niveau 2 contre 0 en 2018
à quoi attribuez-vous ces événements
vous avez parlé de geste inadaptée et
après je n'ai pas très bien compris de
franchissement de je ne sais plus de
quoi notamment dans la centrale de
golfech
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
quelques détails merci je suis tout ouïe
on va laisser une première réponse
ensuite et puis celle des messieurs
problème
alors tout d'abord sur le réexamen de
sûreté des réacteurs de 900 mégawatts
donc ce qui a été indiqué tout à l'heure
par les résultats c'est que à ce stade
nous n'envisageons pas de report sur la
prise de décisions générique qui est
prévue à la fin de l'année 2020 pour
l'ensemble des réacteurs de 900
mégawatts donc les études qui peuvent
être plus facilement être réalisées à
distance les discussions que nous avons
eues au sein du collège des commissaires
de l'asn nous ont permis de faire
avancer ce dossier à peu près
normalement
et donc nous nous envisageons une prise
de position sur l'aspect génériques à la
fin de cette année c'est indépendant
bien évidemment des opérations qui sont
réalisés sur les sites et glas qui
dépendent d'edf et des capacités de
mobilisation des équipes d'edf et des
prestataires pour réaliser les
opérations de contrôle ou pour réaliser
les opérations de modifications qui sont
prévues au moment des arrêts décennaux à
ce stade
au vu des discussions que nous avons
avec edf nous n'entrevoyons pas de
difficulté majeure sur le respect du
calendrier des visites décennales
mais comme ce sont des visites qui sont
plus lourdes en termes d'enjeux
notamment pour les réacteurs de 900
mégawatts
qui sont qui doivent faire l'objet d'une
autorisation de l'asn délivré à l'issue
du réexamen a réalisé réacteur par
réacteur bien évidemment il est
important que le calendrier soit
respecté
d'autant que la limite déchéance de 10
ans est une limite qui est fixé par la
loi et qui dépend d'une directive
européenne
pour l'ensemble des pays de l'union
donc c'est un sujet qui mérite une
grande vigilance car les leviers ne sont
pas les mêmes que ceux que nous
utilisons de manière régulière pour
déplacer d'une semaine ou deux telle ou
telle opération de contrôle suivant la
réglementation française là nous avons
les leviers pour le faire nous avons
l'habitude de le faire donc c'est ce que
nous allons faire pour les écarts qui
ont été identifiés à ce stade mais pour
ce qui concerne les réacteurs de 900
mégawatts
une vigilance particulière est
nécessaire parce que les enjeux sont
beaucoup plus forts mais à ce stade nous
n'avons pas détecté de problème
spécifique en ce qui concerne le la
question de la de la flexibilité ou de
deux des conséquences du mix énergétique
dans le contexte actuel le principal
souci qui doit être le nôtre et celui de
marié les objectifs de sûreté nucléaire
avec ceux de sécurité d'alimentation
électrique la crise qu'ovide telle
qu'elle se présente va avoir
inévitablement on compte tenu des des
allongements des arrêts ou des reports
d'arrêt une baisse de la production
électrique au moins sur l'hiver 2020
est ce que nous nous voulons attirer
comme attention c'est la nécessité de
gérer cette période de telle manière que
des marges pour la sûreté reste
disponible de telle manière que si nous
avions à prendre une décision en matière
de sûreté
par exemple un arrêt ponctuel d'un
réacteur parce qu'un défaut a été
détectée voir un examen sur plusieurs
réacteurs parce que c'est un défaut
générique il puisse y avoir des marges
par rapport à l'année
ces sites et de production de
l'électricité pour que cette décision de
sûreté soient prises
les recteurs vont plutôt fonctionner un
niveau supérieur à celui qu'il pourrait
fonctionner si la totalité des capacités
d'énergie renouvelable étaient
disponibles parce qu'en fait ces
réacteurs seront moins nombreux
connecter au réseau du fait de la
prolongation des arrêts et du nombre de
travaux à réaliser
donc en ce qui concerne donc les enjeux
pour nous c'est vraiment l'enjeu de
disposer de marges suffisantes
et ça ça nécessite une programmation
extrêmement fine des arts et de la part
d'edf
pour ce qui concerne les questions de
l'après ville bon pour ceux pour le p r
depuis depuis la découverte d'un certain
nombre d'anomalies sur sur ce réacteur
il a été demandé a effectivement edf
d'étendre les investigations qui ont été
réalisés sur les différents circuits et
c'est le résultat de ces investigations
complémentaires qui ont conduit à
détecter un certain nombre de soudures
qui ne sont pas conformes et qui doivent
elles-mêmes être corrigées elles sont
beaucoup plus accessibles
elles sont pas des soudures de traverser
et edf s'est engagé dès à présent dans
les opérations de qualification et de
réparation de ses soudures et donc c'est
suture à réparer sont en plus grand
nombre
mais à ce stade nous n'avons pas
identifié de difficultés en termes de
planification pour qu'elles soient
réparées dans le calendrier qui a été
affichée par edf en ce qui concerne le
référentiel grand chaud et la question
de la limitation des débits des rivières
lorsque en situation d'étiage sévère le
cours d'eau est faible la problématique
qui se pose à l'exploitant nucléaire et
celle du rejet puisque la dilution du
rejet ne peut pas être assurée dans les
mêmes conditions qu est conscient
normale et les sites nucléaires dispose
à ce jour de capacité d'entreposage des
rejets liquides notamment donc y sont
stockées en attendant que l'intruse la
situation a évolué pour pouvoir ensuite
les rejeter au milieu naturel en les
diluant si ce n'est pas possible c'est à
dire si la période d'étiage est trop
long
à ce moment là c'est le réacteur qui se
met à l'arrêt de telle manière à ne pas
produire d'effluents donc ces procédures
existent à la fois pour les rejets dans
le milieu naturel comme d'ailleurs les
procédures en ce qui concerne de risques
liés à la température de l'eau qui ne
permettrait plus d'assurer
refroidissement conséquent et ceci ne
pose pas de difficultés en terme de
gestion en revanche que nous constatons
c'est que les événements de caniculaire
sont de plus en plus longs et répétés et
à ce moment là il est effectivement
difficile de maintenir des conditions de
fonctionnement sûr à l'intérieur des
bâtiments notamment pour des effets de
températures intérieures des bâtiments
je vais les dispositifs de sûreté qui
ont été installés sur les centrales ont
été qualifiés pour des températures
maximum si ces températures sont au delà
de ces maximum cela pose des difficultés
et donc ça suppose la mise en place de
systèmes de refroidissement de
conditionnement d'air supplémentaire à
l'intérieur des bâtiments pour conserver
l'opérabilité des équipements de sûreté
et tout ceci repose sur un révision de
l'aléa
c'est à dire une réflexion sur
finalement au vu du contexte historique
au vu des projections qui peut être fait
quel est le niveau de température
enveloppe auquel chaque réacteur et ses
différentes zones géographiques à
l'autre doit être préparée à résister
c'est ça le référentiel grand chaud
nouveau que nous avons demandé à edf
pour redéfinir l'aléa de telle manière à
définir quels sont les équipements qui
sont nécessaires pour pouvoir
fonctionner dans des conditions sûres
alors qu'en ce qui concerne les
événements de niveau 2 que j'ai signalé
comme étant effectivement un signe de 2
de recul de la rigueur d'exploitation en
2019 ce qui est ce qui a été marquant
c'est là dit elle
le franchissement de certaines barrières
de sûreté qui sont débarqués de sûreté
extrêmement connue sur des principes qui
sont bien connues des opérateurs et qui
en l'occurrence n'ont pas été respectées
ce qui pose la question de la culture de
sûreté
je vais prendre l'exemple du
franchissement de la ligne de défense
sur la centrale nucléaire de penly c'est
un exemple qui attirait particulièrement
notre attention il est ponctuel mais il
est significatif d'une perte de repères
de la part de certains intervenants
lorsque l'on intervient dans des
opérations de maintenance sur des
tableaux électriques
le tabloïd fric qui qui commandent des
systèmes de sûreté
une règle de sûreté assez classique ses
tableaux sont redondants une voix à vous
a b c de ne pas intervenir en même temps
ou sur la voir et sur la vab et ne pas
faire la même chose sur la voie et sur
la voie b ce que si on fait une erreur
on fait une erreur sur les deux voies
lors d'un arrêt sur la centrale
nucléaire de penly le l'intervention qui
était prévu sur un des tableaux
électriques n'a pas pu être réalisés et
donc il a été décidé par l'équipe du
site de reporter cette intervention à
l'arrêt suivant est à l'arrêt suivant
ils sont intervenus sur les deux voies
en même temps malheureusement un certain
nombre de composants qui ont été mis sur
les tableaux électriques se sont avérées
défectueuses
il n'y a pas eu de conséquence directe
pour la sûreté
mais il y avait une un risque que les
deux tableaux électriques soient
défaillants puisqu'ils ont fait l'objet
d'interventions de maintenance en même
temps et d'implantation d'équipements
nouveaux qui est se sont avérées tous
les deux défaillant c'est finalement le
franchissement d'une barrière de sûreté
qui est assez connu est le fait d'avoir
volontairement franchi cette barrière
ça pose problème c'est ça l'exemple
société exactement exactement parce que
la rigueur d'exploitation est à la fois
fait de compétences il faut que les
compétences soient présentés
mobilisables mais il faut qu'il y ait
aussi une conscience professionnelle une
conscience que l'on intervient sur des
composants de sûreté et que c'est la
sûreté nucléaire etc
il est très important de le faire donc
il ya à la fois la culture de sûreté et
la compétence des intervenants
voilà l'exemple kia qui nous incite à
dire attention il y a un besoin de
procès this man en matière de rigueur
d'exploitation et et et juste pour
continuer sur cette question j'ai le
président vous évoquez aussi la
saturation des capacités d'ingénierie
d'edf à laquelle vous assistiez est ce
que quand vous parlez de saturation des
capacités vous évoquer ces questions de
rigueur et conscience professionnelle ou
aussi des questions de d'effectifs
voilà c'est clairement une charge de
travail c'est à dire que edf un
programme extrêmement ambitieux c'est
très louable le grand carénage qui va
au-delà du simple réexamen tout ceci
nécessite un travail préparatoire d'un
générique conséquente des ressources
d'un site d'ingénierie sont sont ce
qu'elles sont elles sont limitées
mais ces ressources sont extrêmement
sollicités et nous le voyons bien
lorsque nous dialoguons avec en ce qui
concerne la planification d'une
opération de modification souvent
l'élément qui est avancé c'est nous
n'avons pas la capacité immédiate de
travailler sur ce projet il faut
planifier éventuellement cette
modification
un peu plus tard parce que nous ne
pouvons pas réaliser ce que nous dit edf
cette modification immédiatement donc il
ya une saturation de ses capacités de
travail de deux des équipes d'ingénierie
ce qui a été fait sur le site de
tricastin et est assez est assez
remarquable
nous avons nous mêmes constaté que le
le réexamen de ce premier réacteur s'est
bien passé il s'est bien passé parce que
les services d'ingénierie centraux
conçoivent une modification
mais cette modification qui est adapté
un parc générique peut devoir être
adaptées au contexte local
toutes les installations ne sont pas
parfaitement identiques pour pouvoir
adapter la modification qui a été conçu
au niveau central
il faut que les équipes des équipes
d'ingénierie locale kgo décembre bien
l'installation puisse voir ce qu'il faut
modifier dans la modification qui a été
prévu ceci suppose de la modique de la
mobilisation d'un générique central et
local des équipes spécialisées
d'ingénierie ont été déployés sur le
site de tricastin pour réussir avec
succès la première bd 4 du site de
tricastin
c'est très bien mais la question que
nous nous posons c'est est-ce concevable
de le faire sur tous les sites sachant
que certaines années il y aura quatre ou
cinq visites décennales en même temps
sur le parc nucléaire
ça nécessite des moyens d'ingénierie
certainement supplémentaire et c'est le
point que nous voulons souligner
attention il ya une saturation les
délais d'étude sont longs et la
mobilisation de l'ingénierie locales ne
posera des difficultés si elle doit être
faite sur l'ensemble des réacteurs qui
vont connaître leur réexamen de sûreté
dans les années à venir
merci monsieur le président je le dis
que je donnerai la parole à bruno sido
non cédric ayant pu et bruno sido
monsieur le président j'aurais de
questions à vous poser la première c'est
que avec la crise de lakovic 19
on imagine bien que le niveau de
préoccupation des français aujourd'hui
il se focalise sur les moyens en terme
de santé moyens des hôpitaux et que dans
les futurs arbitrages budgétaires on est
des priorités nouvelles notamment la
question de la santé est ce que est ce
que vous pensez que cela peut avoir une
conséquence sur le sur les choix
budgétaires en termes de sûreté
nucléaire c'est à dire est ce que ça
peut entraîner des reports est ce que
par exemple sur les mesures qui avaient
été imaginés post-fukushima
ces mesures qui ont été décidées est-ce
que des futurs choix budgétaires feront
courir un risque de retard
c'était ma première question et puis la
seconde question porte sur la culture du
risque dans notre pays est-ce que vous
pensez que la culture du risque est au
niveau adéquat suffisant je pense et ce
n'est qu'un exemple à la question des
pastis yoda retirer en pharmacie je vous
remercie
sur la première question je ne n'ai pas
d'éléments en particulier à me
permettant de me répondre je les choix
budgétaires ne sont sûrs ne sont pas
connus à ce stade et une partie des
mesures post fukushima une grande partie
des mesures post fukushima ont été
d'ores et déjà mises en place
il reste quelques cas particuliers
notamment les diesels d'ultime secours
qui connaissent quelques retards chez
edf la mise en place de centres de crise
bunkérisé au cea par exemple mais ces
projets sont en cours et il devrait
logiquement déboucher dans les mois à
venir et pas au delà dont je ne pense
pas financièrement très peu étriqué je
vais venir je parlais je parlais des
mesures post fukushima donc en ce qui
concerne post fukushima sera le dixième
anniversaire de l'accident de fukushima
à l'année prochaine nous serons nous
france un exploitant et autorités
regarder avec attention sur ce qui a été
fait en termes d'engagement de respect
des engagements de d'amélioration de la
sûreté face à des conditions extrêmes
sur les sites
il ya un certain nombre de retards mais
qui sont explicables et qui devraient
pouvoir se combler dans les mois à venir
et je ne pense pas que les choix
budgétaires puissent influencer la mise
en place des mesures post fukushima
en revanche et là monsieur le président
vous avez tout à fait raison c'est un
point que j'ai souligné tout à l'heure
c'est un autre volet qui lui est un
volet particulier celui de la reprise du
conditionnement des déchets anciens et
le démantèlement des installations pour
le démantèlement des installations là on
est sur des choix budgétaires notamment
pour le cea qui dépend dans les
ressources dépendent totalement du
budget de l'état s'est pas forcément ce
n'est pas le cas pour edf par exemple et
bien évidemment nous avons dans le cadre
de
de l'étude que nous avons réalisé avec
l'autorité sûreté nucléaire de défense
attirer l'attention du gouvernement sur
le fait que les ressources qu'ils
étaient alloués à ces opérations qui
sont budgétisés jusqu'à hauteur de 740
millions d'euros jusqu'en 2022 devait
être maintenu voire augmenté au delà
pour pouvoir réaliser dans le planning
prévu par le ceva les opérations de
démantèlement
il y assure le site de marcoule et sur
le site de saclay quelques points
sensibles d'installation très ancienne
qui comporte un terme source qui est
encore relativement élevé et qu'il
faudrait pouvoir évacuer assez
rapidement et c'est sur ce point que
nous avons insisté auprès du premier
ministre qui a nous a répondu et qui
nous a indiqué en avril de cette année
le souci qu'il avait de 2,10 doter le
cea des moyens suffisants pour assurer
les opérations de démantèlement et de
reprise des déchets anciens dans le
planning qui avait été validé j'ose
espérer que ce courrier ne sera pas
remise en cause dans le cadre des
discussions budgétaires prochaine
d'accord je reviens sur sur la deuxième
question deuxième question elle me
paraît fondamental fondamentale et d'une
certaine manière c'est un peu le retour
d'expérience de louise 2
de ces 18 mois de mandat qui viennent de
s'écouler en ce qui me concerne je pense
et vous avez cité aussi présent tout à
l'heure en parlant de l'anticipation des
enjeux du besoin d'anticipation des
enjeux je pense qu'il y a un déficit de
culture de précaution dans notre pays et
qui s'applique également à la situation
du nucléaire
je vais prendre trois exemples depuis de
nombreuses années l'asn attire
l'attention sur l'insuffisance des
capacités d'entreposage des combustibles
usés
ça a été dit à plusieurs reprises et
dans le plan actuel peine j'aime dr pour
qu'il y ait effectivement la mise en
place de nouvelles capacités
d'entreposage des combustibles usés il y
avait une obligation faite à edf de
déposer une demande d'autorisation de
création pour une stèle installations
pour la fin de cette année cette
échéance ne sera pas respectée et
pourtant nous l'ensemble des exploitants
nucléaires savent que cette capacité
supplémentaire d'entre eux posent à elle
est nécessaire elle est nécessaire parce
qu'il ya déjà un très haut niveau de
saturation des piscines d'entreposage de
lag et en cas d'aléas sur une
installation de retraitement par exemple
c'est la totalité de la filière qui
seraient en difficulté
s'il n'y avait pas des capacités
d'entreposage la solution de
l'entreposage à sac prendra aussi
beaucoup de temps et néanmoins malgré
ces alertes répétées
il n'y a pas eu suffisamment de volonté
pour pouvoir trouver une solution face à
ce risque de manque de capacité
d'entreposage de volonté ou quoi de
volonté de la part des exploitants en
général
cc c'est tout à fait clair le deuxième
exemple c'est celui que vous avez cités
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé recueillir un
site d'entre eux posent c'est clair
c'est clair alors avoir accueilli un
site un peu particulier je peux aussi il
sentiment d'être un original on parle de
quelle de kehl le
surface de quel volume quel ordre de
grandeur le projet le projet qui ait
fait l'objet d'un d'une présence d'un
d'oriental validation des orientations
de sûreté piscine le projet de piscine
centralisée d'edf
de mémoire je voudrais pas dire de
bêtises mais je pense qu'il s'agit de
deux piscines qui sont de l'ordre de
grandeur d'une piscine olympique c'est
ça une piscine olympique s'est pas
immense
c'est pas immense alors bien évidemment
raison de sa présidence et on l'a mais
c'est c'est pas facile
bon donc il faut y réfléchir mais en
revanche le problème est connu il est
connu depuis longtemps et et construire
une telle installation
ça va prendre dix ans donc c'est
vraiment urgent c'est un alors ça fait
partie des conclusions du débat public
l'entreposage sec existent aux anneaux
maîtrise totalement la technologie ils
elles mêmes
il la met en oeuvre à l'étranger donc
c'est pas c'est pas un sujet de
technologie mail alors annuler ces ora
nos qui sera demain mais il ya quelques
millions il faut travailler sur ce
projet ça aussi ça prendra un certain
temps
tout ne peut pas être entreposés à sec
il faut de toute façon une première
phase de refroidissement sous zoo le mox
ne peut pas être entreposés à sec
facilement donc on voit bien que les
solutions sont compliquées mais il faut
trouver une solution parce que c'est un
défaut un défaut de précaution par
rapport à un problème qui est clairement
identifié je viens sur la le point on
peut souligner c'est la pré campagne de
distribution de comprimés d'iodé
il ya eu de très large communication sur
ce sujet des pouvoirs publics des cli de
la scène sur le thème avoir chez soi des
comprimés diodes
c'est une mesure de protection au cadre
d'incidents nucléaires avec des rejets
radioactifs et le préfet peut décider
dans des temps relativement court
de demander à la population de prendre
ces comprimés et pourtant malgré
plusieurs opérations sur la dernière
campagne réalisée en 2019
seuls 25% des français dans les zones
concernées sont allé retirer en
pharmacie les comprimés diodes
il ya un défaut de culture de précaution
de risque de culture de risques on n'est
pas assez conscients que finalement
c'est un outil indispensable pour se
protéger pourraient faire un parallèle
avec les masques comment cela se compare
avec d'autres pays
question diodes par exemple je n'ai pas
d'éléments mais c'est un point sur
lequel je creuse rey et le troisième le
troisième exemple qu'on peut prendre
c'est celui de queue qui a été aussi à
plusieurs reprises souligné par l'asn en
termes de maintien des marges en matière
de production de capacités de production
d'électricité pour pouvoir faire face à
un événement qui imposerait l'arête
réacteur ça c'est déjà réalisé lorsque
l'asn a demandé l'arrêt de certains
réacteurs pour vérifier l'état de défaut
des générateurs de vapeur
parce qu'il y avait des suspicions de
ces régressions carbone plusieurs
réacteurs se sont arrêtés sur une courte
période pour aller faire ses
vérifications de sûreté ça s'est produit
juste avant un pic hivernal
donc il faut il faut faire attention de
conserver des marges dans l'est dans les
stratégies publiques en termes de
politique énergétique
attention à conserver des marges pour
que l'on puisse faire face à des
problèmes de sûreté
donc il y a d'une certaine manière a
réinsisté me semble-t-il sur cette
nécessité d'avoir une culture de
précaution merci monsieur le président
sur la question débattue rebattues et
que vous avez évoqué de le p r
flamanville est-ce qu'on peut revenir en
détail sur et actuel les différentes
étapes et bien vérifier qu'elles sont le
sous quelle forme le sujet va revenir
à l'office dans le futur sur la question
de la prolongation des réacteurs de 900
mégawatts aux dates 40 ans vous avez
parlé du calendrier des étapes du
processus
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler les
différents éléments qui sont les plus
les plus clé dans l'appréciation ceux
qui sont plus subtiles que d'autres
diraient à quel état d'un niveau de
certitude sur l'ensemble en êtes vous et
puis une troisième question en 2018 vous
présentiez devant notre fils votre avis
sur l'identification de sujets de
recherche approfondir en matière de
sûreté nucléaire et de radioprotection
sur ces questions de sujets de recherche
à approfondir
est ce que dans quelle mesure ces
recommandations ont elles été pris en
compte
et est ce qu'il ya lieu de les
reformuler dorée insisté dessus alors ce
qui concerne le p r on a beaucoup parlé
des soudures
mais bon ce n'est pas le seul sujet bien
évidemment qui concerne l'installation
il y a eu au cours de l'année 2019
toute une série de décès les ca froide
essai à chaud de tests qui ont été
réalisés sur l'installation et qui ont
pour la plupart démontrer que cette
installation était correctement réalisés
et qu'elle pouvait effectivement être
mise en fonctionnement donc les
résultats des essais sont plutôt
satisfaisants il ya toujours des choses
à plat sur a corrigé à l'issue des
essais mais cette étape indispensable
dans le processus de mise en service a
été franchi avec succès
c'est sur les équipements les plus
lourds qui qu'il faut avoir une
vigilance on a parlé des soudures mais
nous avons aussi demandé à edf d'étendre
sa revue sur de conception et de
fabrication sur d'autres équipements
autres que des tuyauteries mais qui sont
essentiels à la sûreté donc ce sont des
systèmes de sûreté pour s'assurer qu'il
n'y avait pas d' ado manille qui
n'auraient pas été détectée nous avons
demandé à edf de nous fournir un bilan
sur cette revue
que nous n'avons pas encore reçu mais ce
plan est en cours et ce qui nous
permettra d'avoir une vision globale à
la fois sur la réalisation des essais
qui sont nécessaires la remise à niveau
des installations qui sont défectueuses
et puis le contrôle de tous les
équipements importants pour la sûreté à
ce stade comme je l'indiquais tout à
l'heure les les contacts que nous avons
avec edf ne nous conduise pas à
identifier de difficultés particulières
dont le processus de qualification et
dans le processus de remise en état mais
les opérations de soudage qui ont
commencé sur le site pour les soudures
qui sont accessibles qui n'ont pas
encore commencé pour les soudures de
traverser enceinte puisqu'il faut
d'abord qualifié les modes opératoires
c'est un prestataire américain
les premières opérations de mise au
point du procédé de réparation par la
traversée sont en train d'être réalisées
aux états unis et donc tout ceci va
prendre un certain temps mais à notre
connaissance il n'y a pas de retard de
planning nous avons également cette
année à instruire une demande formulée
par edf de d'un provisionnement des
combustibles 9 qui pourrait être donc
acheminés vers la centrale de ppr de
flamanville et entreposés dans les
piscines
sur le fond ce cette demande ne pose pas
de difficultés particulières en revanche
l'autorisation a été différée du fait
que l' ordonnance du 25 mars ne nous
permettait pas de réaliser des
consultations du public donc ça va être
fait donc logiquement ce combustible
neuf pourrait être autorisé à rejoindre
la centrale de flamanville courant de
cette année donc globalement le
processus de préparation de le p r ou de
remise en état le père ou de contrôle de
l'opn semble se passer normalement par
rapport au planning qui a été affichée
mais évidemment je je ne peux pas
préjuger de ce qui se passera par là par
la suite
pour ce qui concerne la prolongation
d'exploitation des réacteurs de 900
mégawatts nous sommes vraiment en phase
finale d'élaboration de la ville
générique qui sera mise en consultation
du public à la fin de cette année reste
encore quelques points de discussion
sensible avec avec edf et nous attendons
leur ultime proposition avant de statuer
7 ces points concernent par exemple
l'épaississement du radier au radier ccc
le fond du direct du bâtiment réacteur
c'est le sol qui n'a pas la même
épaisseur sur toutes les centrales de
900 mégawatts et certains radié à
épaisseur plus faibles ont été fabriqués
avec des bétons précis 10e et c'est
béton très siliceux ne résiste pas
suffisamment au risque de percement du
radier en cas de corium en fusion et
donc la question se pose si pour
certains de ses réacteurs
il faut épaissir le radier et de gros
bien voilà c'est un débat que nous avons
qui nécessitent des tests particulier
des essais un programme d'essai mais sur
les cuves elle-même nous n'avons pas de
sujets particuliers qui restent à
traiter
voilà un exemple le bon il reste donc
quelques cas pas très nombreux mais qui
ne sont pas encore totalement tranché
sur lesquels nous échangeons avec edf et
nous nous prévoyons de trancher pour
pour cet été l'irsn a rendu son avis de
synthèse sur l'ensemble des études
réalisées par edf donc cet avis a été
rendu public début avril et nous
consulterons le groupe permanent
d'experts les groupe permanent d'experts
de l'asn en septembre sur le projet de
décision qui ensuite sera mis en
consultation publique à la fin de cette
année donc le processus avance il reste
quelques points
nous pensons aujourd'hui que il y aura
vraisemblablement de la part de l'asn la
prescription de deux modifications
additionnels par rapport à celles qui
ont été
proposé par edf pour couvrir l'ensemble
des champs qui les objectifs qui avaient
été identifiés dans le cadre du réexamen
des réacteurs de 900 mégawatts dont
l'objectif est de se rapprocher le plus
possible du niveau de sûreté des
réacteurs de troisième génération comme
celui de le perdre donc il y a eu des
propositions d'edf en termes de mode
modifications il ya une instruction
lourde qui est arrivé quasiment à son
terme il reste quelques sujets encore en
suspens est vrai ça normand la
conclusion de tout cela d'ici la fin de
l'année nous conduira à prescrire
quelques modifications additionnel qui
concerne les sujets de recherche
donc nous nous nous réévaluons avec
notre comité scientifique de manière
régulière les thématiques de recherche à
privilégier nous n'avons pas de moyens
financiers pour inciter les organismes
de recherche à réaliser des actions de
recherche dans les domaines que nous
identifions donc nous sommes dans une
situation un peu difficile ce travail
est fait mais ensuite nous nous essayons
de porter la bonne parole auprès des
instituts nationaux de recherche ou
auprès du ministère de la recherche pour
que les porteurs de projet intègre les
thématiques prioritaires de recherche
que nous identifions je ne cache pas que
c'est très difficile c'est très
difficile d'avoir un pouvoir d'influencé
sans avoir un moyen d'actionner les
moyens financiers mais c'est ce que nous
faisons et nous essayons de travailler
le plus possible avec libérées saines
qui disposent de moyens de recherche
pour que les thématiques de recherche
prioritaires que nous identifions si
elles ne peuvent pas être portés par des
centres de recherche extérieure soit
intégrée dans les axes de recherche de
l'irsn
nous avons des axes de recherche qui
porte sur le vieillissement
c'est bien évidemment en lien avec la
propre la prolongation d'exploitation
des centrales nucléaires pas seulement
sur les sujets classiques et des
matériaux métalliques comme la cuve qui
est bien évidemment un composant
essentiel mais sur lequel il ya eu
beaucoup de travaux de recherche
réalisés par le passé mais sur des
composants un peu différent les câbles
par exemple
donc les polymères les câbles se sont
déçus les bétons il ya donc il ya des
sujets qui sortent un peu du chant très
largement débattue est explorée par les
organismes de recherche
mais nous avons aussi des propositions
de recherche dans le domaine médical et
il y a il ya une nécessité d'avoir une
meilleure connaissance des impacts
notamment des faibles doses de la
l'exposition répétée des patients et des
enfants par exemple au scanner donc tout
ceci nécessite des études de longue
durée pour lesquels nous essayons de
portée de ce message auprès des
organismes de recherche
c'était l'audition organisée par le
sénat sur le rapport annuel de l'agencé
de sûreté nucléaire autour de la
sécurité des centrales nucléaires en
france en 2019 c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi pour
continuer à vous informer sur cette
crise sanitaire
n'hésitez pas à aller sur notre site
publicsenat.fr je vous souhaite une très
bonne journée sur public sénat
[Musique]
m